[Music]
a winning position / I wanted it so bad
and he did it happy Thursday everybody
welcome back to the I am non-gm speed
chess championship brought to you by
chess comm we're here today with
international masters John Bartholomew
and Lawrence Trent and I'm just gonna
get right to it and I'm gonna start with
you Lawrence what will it take from you
to beat somebody up John Bartholomew's
caliber
oh look I mean John he's been touted as
the tournament favorites you know that
he's gonna walk through this field
without too many difficulties you know
he's a very handsome young man as you
will see but you know he's going to be a
tough test but you know I've got some
things to say about John that may that a
lot of you may agree with or may
disagree with and as a lot of you know I
played cards a lot and in cards we call
a player who doesn't like risk doesn't
like action and NIT and John is the
equivalent of an it in chess this is a
guy who enjoys bringing his Queen out on
the move to only to then put it back on
its starting square I'll move three be
slightly worse and actually derive
pleasure from doing that this guy who is
pretty pretty much as Eric Rosen 2.0 he
is a you know to aspire to be this kind
of chess player well I'm really sorry
guys that's not the way to go and today
I have one mission and one mission and
that is to get this guy in a dog fight
there's no other way I'm gonna get him
in the mud wrestling with just his jocks
on me in him and that is it he's a great
player he is the favorite on paper but
if I get him into a scrap I think I've
got good chances and we're gonna put
this knit in his place
Wow well I think we should have a moment
of silence that was a soliloquy worthy
of a Shakespeare play fight that's quite
the introductory speech John you had a
very convincing victory in your
first-round matchup
or shall I call you Eric 2.0 so Eric 2.0
what kind of lessons did you learn it
was a very convincing one against
international master David Bruce but
what things are you going to try to
improve what small improvements are you
going to try to make to contest your
very worthy and very bloodthirsty
opponents
yeah look I mean what Lawrence just said
makes perfect sense I agree with a lot
of that I think his strategy is optimal
and playing someone like me and to
Lawrence's credit I thought he played an
excellent match against Costa Chica
boots key so I watched a good portion of
that and Lawrence you were you're on
fire really you were seeing a lot of
stuff and when Lawrence gets in there
and mixes it up and I forgot what you
said about the jocks that must be a
English expression about familiar with
that but when you get in there and mix
it up and you're on firing on all
cylinders you're quite hard to stop but
I do think my style causes problems for
you
and it is a good stylistic matchup I
think the audience is gonna enjoy it
today when win or lose and as far as
what I learned from the previous match
I've just honestly been focusing a lot
on my own game especially in the past
year in playing online in what sit
bullet so I'm definitely one of those
players I don't try to over adjust or
make too many changes based on what has
happened in the short term I just play
my game I'm confident with it I mean ya
do an overall seed here but I don't
really put much stock in that I mean
this is one tournament unexpected stuff
can happen in any match I do think the
online players have a significant edge
as has been borne out in the standings
thus far but I'm confident just playing
my game so that's that's my needy answer
to your your question Oh Lord I'm gonna
ask you does it hurt anymore
get when you try to call John out and
you really just you put it to him and he
just joins with this nice mid why my
plan behind me would have given a more I
mean this guy makes sure I mean what's
he doing on the chess board he should be
in politics I couldn't give a thrilling
answer if it slept with him and made him
coffee in the morning I'd appreciate
that yeah I mean look it's time to get
this Midwest and a smiley handsome guy
off the airwaves he is just taking up
space here and it's time to put the real
chest the chest that everybody loves the
blood on the board back on the map I'm
not here to knit it up with John Bartle
lit up he can do his very
I promise you I'm gonna be throwing the
kitchen sink at him and if he wins a
match if I can say afterwards I gave it
my all I threw everything at him and he
still beats me
fair play but I'm gonna make sure he
works for it and what damn heart I would
hope so yeah I'm ready to get it on Wow
well let's do it so I'm let's go on that
note we're gonna let you get settled in
and get ready for this match I'm excited
just buy this pre match interview
everybody will be back to just a few and
when we return we will have the opening
games of this matchup between John
Bartholomew and Lawrence Wright
[Music]
and let us remind everybody but the
bracket of this I am NOT GM speed chess
championship because it's been throwing
series of events thus far and as we see
here we look across the bracket we see
John Bartholomew taking on Lawrence
trend the upper left the winner of this
match faces the winner of tonight's
matchup between charissa yep and Gregg
jihadi and while we talked the players
before head and they're all rooting for
Carissa over Gregg they said I'm going
to have a great day out street easy as
long as Gregg Shahadah loses but Dania
when you look at this bracket we see
Teddy Coleman and even catch the sky and
the semies on the right side who do you
think are the favorites on the left well
in this particular match and I think if
I say what I'm about to say Lawrence
might pause the match booked a flight to
the US and come after me but I'm gonna
have to go with John I'll explain that
shortly in terms of the evening match
for which I will be unable to join your
Robert but I'm gonna have to go with
charissa there is a certain rumor about
a certain device with which Karissa
makes moves I will not elaborate on that
further and I'm looking at Alina who has
played incredibly well and I think she
is the favorite to be Teddy Coleman so
we have some fascinating matchups ahead
and this is the first of them yes let's
take a look at our two players in this
match because John Bartholomew is number
one seed and he's probably everybody's
presumptive favorite Lee's coming into
this tournament but we've seen some
fighting chests from all of the
participants including as you mentioned
Lina conscience kaya Teddy Coleman and
as we see John Bartholomew he's rated
nearly 27-hundred and blitz his bullet
rating is about 2600 and that's
typically without increment and on
Lawrence Trent and he's in that 2500
rating range but once again without the
increment and Daniel what do you think
about these two duking it out who does
the increment favor that's a great
question I will admit that I'm well I'm
thoroughly familiar with Lawrence's
banter and his multiple soliloquies I am
less familiar with his actual Blitzen
bullet practice so I'm not sure about
his speed maybe you can
me with that Robert in terms of John's
play he likes the increment John is not
a huge fan of wild time scrambles he's a
very very solid player and with that one
second edition he's absolutely a force
to be reckoned with and he's also very
fast so he's definitely not against that
increment but what do you know about
Lawrence Trent's blitz and bullet skills
um well you know I know I can't say what
I want to say on air I am hired by this
company so yeah I'm gonna keep it to
myself but I'm ready for liftoff we will
see we don't have to talk Lawrence is a
lot of talk and John is saying I'm gonna
let my moves do the talking for me we're
about to have liftoff here and see the
opening games the five-minute portion in
fact we are underway I see that John is
the white pieces will Lawrence play
something offbeat try take it to jump or
thumb you will John solid style prevail
Daniel I very off beat very offbeat you
know big really what is this open never
seen this before in my life responding
to the Queen's pawn opening with the
Queen's pawn move of you and clearly
Lawrence is never seen sunk into opened
area what are you doing Lawrence what is
this guy up to I'm going to take it to
that Midwestern and it's going to be a
bloodthirsty match no John wish if F for
you you know work on your Lawrence
someone be honest with you I do i do
I'll unveil it a little bit later okay
but John playing Bishop before he's
playing very solidly we saw in his first
round matchup against David Bruce John
is the epitome of solid positionally
sound chess he's very very hard to beat
and he certainly doesn't beat himself
very often how does Lawrence deal with
that it's gonna be difficult because
Lawrence is a guy who just loves chaos
on the board and he's trying to create
it he put a 6 in innocuous-looking move
on the second turn of the game and I
would say not a very good one
but in actually in many lines it can be
handy to just prevent anything happening
on the Queen side but then again
sometimes you wish that punk could go
back to a 7 - sure up some of the
squares on the Queen side so I'm not
really buying the opening for black but
then again look at the clock
Lawrence's are
20 seconds and jump is Queen dy that's
the exact thing Lauren just making fun
of playing Queen back to d1 for no real
reason and I'm just checking in on
Lawrence's facial expression we don't
see any grins or any smiles just yet I
think horns realizes that he doesn't
have an advantage here but c5 striking
in the center now after D takes e5
Lawrence has got another decision to
make this he simply recapture on c5 does
he play 94 and try to pounce immediately
I'm not sure if Queen d1 was the best
way to solve sort of the dynamic
problems in White's position it seems
like Jon's lack of development on the
Kings side is bothering him a little bit
well why did he play Queen to d1 he
could have just start with Bishop to d3
you want to get that development out the
way Castle kingside
go ahead and do it the Queen was none
any danger on the f3 square and at some
moment perhaps there was even a queen g3
type of idea it wouldn't have worked in
the initial position probably because of
Knight h5 although the more I look at it
Queen g3 is actually quite a tempting
move he instead retreated with Queen to
d1 and we see c5 and now the Queen to a5
and Doni we've talked about this a lot
in blitz games especially piling up on
doubled pawns can be very good for the
site without the double bonds but here
where white has the two bishops and if
this board starts opening up that's
going to be really problematic for
Lawrence yes indeed Lawrence has to be
very very accurate in this position b5
actually came to my minds intending C
takes d5 c4 I feel like that might be in
Lawrence's exploratory style but I don't
think that quite does the trick after
Queen before so you're absolutely right
the problem is white is very very close
to consolidating he just needs to play
Bishop e2 Castle short and those two
bishops will make their presence felt at
the same time black needs to try to
prepare this move 94 but it's very very
hard to do b7 as it is hanging although
not immediately because c3 will be
hanging with check maybe just Bishop d3
for John I'm not sure what's going on
here I'm not sure who's better and I
think the reason you're saying that is
because you're anticipating some kind of
C takes d4 for black D takes c4 really
and we're mentioning how opening the
position should help the side with the
bishops but it also helps the rooks and
blacks work on the C file is creating
more trouble
for white then maybe worth it so it's
actually a tough decision
for John and we see that he's using a
lot of time because C takes d5 very
night 65 hitting the bishop one at four
in this pawn on c3 so it's a difficult
situation for John Bartholomew and he's
down what soon will be a minute on the
clock indeed and Bishop d3 runs into b5
I'm pretty sure and then c4 is simply a
fork where's Bishop e2 as you pointed
out Robert I think John just doesn't
want to waste that tempo developing the
bishop once and then taking on c4 again
he decides on a pretty radical approach
taking on c5 throwing his pawn structure
to the wind but he's carving out that'd
be Foursquare for his queen trying to
get rid of that very very annoying pin
on the c3 pawn and actually Knight c5
Queen before force is a queen trade
because there's no way for you to move
your queen while still protecting your
knight on c5 and if the Queen's come off
and the bishops have their open space
especially if you take me on before I
take with my C pawn I understand why
possibly complain about position like
this absolutely cannot complain and
certainly something like John cannot
complain he likes and games
he likes positional advantages Bishop d6
Bishop d6 here erect upon structure yes
I do you take me on before take with my
C pawn denied to the mc5 is it to the
pawn orthodontist they're forced with
Bishop d6 because if you take first on
c5 and then go Bishop d6 there's real
Pepsi it just illustrates how important
move order is in chess move order almost
always matters Bishop d6 is is is a must
play I think for John I just don't see
an alternative and even after Bishop e6
I don't think Lords disposition is that
bad and I mean I have to be honest I
keep looking at the clock and thinking
that even if Laurence it's a little bit
of trouble he's up so much time that it
will be hard for John to take full
advantage of the reason why I think
black is doing okay rook at the c8 and
ite for very quick ideas just hitting
some of White's pieces and look at your
King still the center not going to be
checkmated but it gives black the
opportunity to unleash quick activity
for instance if you ever take on d5
you've opened the C file for my rook and
black is the one who's activated white
King in the center the King's
pieces not doing anything so I do think
that ultimately it should be totally
fine for Lawrence but it's one of these
positions dunya where the longer you
play the more power the two bishops will
eventually have indeed it can swing
either way and the X Factor is going to
be in my opinion will white be able to
castle play Bishop f3 and retain the
integrity of a structure at the same
time that Rokon c2 is very strong so I
suppose even if John does manage to
castle and Lawrence doubles on the C
file which he does
maybe plays a move like h6 or g6
prophylactically he's got a lot of Peace
activity I'm not sure how to weigh you
know the static and dynamic factors of
the position maybe it's just around
equal yeah these these kind of
equalities very confusing for most
people because when you hear a grandma
say oh it's equal you're like well then
shouldn't just be a draw but I mean I
think that we're looking at this
position saying that both sides have
opportunities in such a position black
has the activity along the C file White
has this long-term advantage of having
the bishop pair but look at Lawrence go
he's reinforcing his knight on d5 and
the c-4 square these Knights can just
keep going forward in this position and
White's bishops don't have clear
diagonals to work with the bishop on d6
looks good but it's not attacking
anything it's staring into empty space
where the Knights are actually poking
and prodding at concrete threats yes
they are and maybe I should give John
the rest of my coffee because he seems
to be a little bit on the slow side here
basically a minute left for him that
rope c1 move though
very prudent because after Knight C for
now there might actually be no actually
Bishop 65 he takes d5 rook takes d5
there might be rook d8 there just a lot
of unpleasantness going on and I'm sure
Lawrence is calculating the Proceedings
of Knight see I'm just showing the
conclusion of in line with rook c1 check
and I'm meeting you because both sides
Tim not green left for their King and
you're just gonna make a love not war
right yeah that's that's a great thing
another another one into the book Knight
c3 though oh that is a risky move
because the b7 bond is potentially on
pre but after Bishop d7 I guess they're
just rook to d8 or 91 well yes and I do
one as well there's no way for the rook
to stay attached to the bishop but I
actually like you
91 of course better because after Bishop
c8 been waited Knight c8 and that rookie
one night 66 and once again black will
strike first in the back rank so John
definitely holding his breath
look at that back rank 92 now Bishop e2
forced Lawrence had both sides of very
weak back rings and both sides have to
decide do they spend a tempo resolving
that problem John trying to plug the C
file with Bishop c5 now Lawrence can
just plant a knight on d5 or denied it
was worried for yeah he's looking
looking quite alarming quite perilous
for white John's not gonna be able to
retain that Bishop on c5 I'm afraid I
like his move g3 though very prudent hey
she's gonna start go ahead no I was just
gonna say at least he's gonna resolve
the problem of the back rank whereas
black still has that problem to solve
and if black takes immediately on c5
which is why I really liked Lawrence's
move Laurens recognizing that if there
were a capture one move of go and c5 bc5
you can't take on c5 because of the back
rank me and you allow a move like rook
to be one to come with a tempo hitting
the pawn on b7 so by delaying this
capture on c5 now you didn't even take
the bishop and he just puts his rooks on
the second rank here the f2 pawn if you
could just add that Knight into the mix
but we saw this yesterday at night on a
four dominated by a bishop on d4 that
night can't go anywhere and as soon as
you move that night I'll probably
capture it and you're being a six pawns
could be quite vulnerable in your future
yeah it looks like and we can see by
Lawrence's facial expression he's
looking looking looking but often times
in these positions you find that
everything is defended as it is here I
feel like whites should be able to hold
a draw here with accurate defense but
but that being said black is holding all
of the cards here you can put his King
on g6 you can even go after that pawn on
b4 which is I'm pretty sure what
Lawrence is trying to do okay for for
example
yes he's looking for wins that pawn
immediately but he's no rush the furqan
f1 is tied down to this pawn f2 and so
now he goes rogue a4 he didn't you know
you could have continued with rook to a2
keeping that rook on f1 for awhile but
he said why don't I just go up a pawn
here put my Brooke in front of the pawn
and this is not going to be an easy win
if it is indeed even winning
the problem is the black king needs to
run into the action but as soon as the
black King runs to the Queen side then
there's rook a seven and I start picking
off your King side pawns and if I have
your pawns then I can sacrifice my rook
for your passed pawn and then some
marching my pawns in my own so what do
you think about this done yet is this
closer to draw territory away this is
probably closer to winning territory as
far as I remember the addition of an
extra pawn on the King side favors the
side with the extra pawn but please take
that wood grain of salt there's this old
Russian saying that these types of head
games can almost be winning for white
because black basically spends all of
his time deciding whether to bring his
King to the other side of the board and
when he does White's tags all of the
King side pawns and then promotes so
here Laurence I'm not sure I think he -
that was a little bit premature this is
it's not an easy draw but it's also not
particularly difficult provided that
John can avoid blunders here this should
be he's got the best pawn structure here
to make that draw yeah and you know
spawned the F 2 G 3 h4 pawns
it is in theoretical draws territory but
black at some point you'll see for
threatening III just to you know
distance the pawns from each other I
sacrifice a pawn to disconnect them so
rook to a3 you really want to enter King
to g4 but John showing accurate defense
hitting his pawn of 6 there's e4 and I
particularly didn't like that because
Laurence had right around 40 seconds on
his clock he could have taken 30 of them
okay he doesn't find anything he goes
for this endgame accumulates those
seconds back pushes and tips is sat off
of John makes the drop but he went for
this with a little bit too much alacrity
and I think John is is very confidently
holding on here with the time to spare
yeah and I think that Laurence needs to
go for g5 it put that King back I have 5
try to go g5 he's doing his best here Oh
King III there would have forced yet
moves
f5 but said the Kings bet and here comes
the King oh wait a second
did I jinx him if you might have roasts
the first instance of commentators f is
for April 30th now F for coming in F for
always bringing the Q around to G - this
is looking very bad now oh my goodness
recheck throw
check imperceptibly he brought his king
over to g4 through the light squares and
now everything collapses rack up three
and after King e2 roof g3 try crook g5
like that's your best effort was Ricci
five they're hoping that you capture on
g5 in my Jeep H phone becomes a jeep on
which becomes a queen and Lawrence Trent
Devon who is this guy I don't know he
he's capable of delivering a
Shakespearean soliloquy he's also
capable of playing like a Russian
schoolboy in the end he's where he has
for the first time in his life he just
made you proud indeed wow that was even
deep and John just totally
expressionless that is also
quintessential John he's done till table
just shakes it off you know man man man
not my game alright next game guys play
solid Slav and you know make a draw
black and that's what he does he he
plays the Slav solid that's what makes
John such a tough player to play in a
match am i exaggerating or do you share
those thoughts Robert
no John is of course a tough customer
but what I think is trouble for him is
if Lords is beating him in technical
positions that's a really bad sign
because as Lawrence was very strongly
not even implied he was just stating
that he said I'm just gonna throw this
guy in the mud and we're gonna have a
tactical affair where John is gonna try
to avoid the tactics at a cost to his
position but if Lawrence is going to win
a technical rook end game against the
ultra solid ultrasound all just sounds
really weird now that I'm out of my
mouth there but against the extremely
sound uh-huh ultrasound John Bartholomew
then that's a problem for JB right if
Lawrence is gonna win eight more games
then we're gonna talk you then we're
gonna be talking about ultrasounds but
h4 he's bringing it to him in he is
Lawrence flush with confidence after
that first win and you can just see he's
just he's just savoring that opportunity
to attack and I'm not sure I like John's
John's looking tired he's looking a
little bit on energetic he's got to
bring the heat here because you don't
want to fall into that hole and dig
yourself dig yourself in a hole in there
really going because and you
spend the rest of the magic climbing
importance was leading 50 feet back in
his chair very surprised at the move age
5 although it seems pretty sensible to
me he's just socially distancing himself
from the chess board right now and King
f1 look at Lawrence what me king of one
is not one of the first five moves that
came to my finalists I mean 10 moves
that came to my brain but he goes King
to f1 and what is he thinking here he
wants to tuck his king away from the
centre but did you need to play that
move King f1 what was the point
I mean Lawrence's brain speaks a
language that I haven't fully understood
yet King f1 F I'm not sure where he's
guess he going to g3 with the king king
g1 king h2 you know teaming short style
but there's a few too many pieces left
on the board for that c5 by John John's
gonna seize his opportunity here sacking
on b5 and that's one of the adjustments
that I think he does have to make from
his match against David now he won that
match on mob sided fashion but in
certain cases he hesitated a little bit
too much and here we see him a little
bit more willing to sack long term for
an initiative yeah because if you take
what the pawn on before is just and
played this pawn it's an isolated pawn
black gets it or Bishop takes f3
I'm not sure I'd want to part with this
wonderful Bishop and long open diagonal
but does shatter White's King side
structures Knight b6 plate first saying
I could take on that three soon but if I
were Lawrence I would retreat my Bishop
to e2 protecting this knight on f3 it's
there can only be one Lawrence oh you
can't be Lawrence you can't pretend to
be Lawrence I mean I taught you to say
if I were Lawrence I talked about this
the last time Lawrence played the band
Lawrence is excellent so and a song of
theirs that I really like is it's not
all about you so it really feels a
little pointed at mr. Trent doesn't it
yeah it's almost as if it was written
for him now Bishop g5 that bishop
kind of ensconced on that square now f6
would be very very weakening I like this
move Queen b6 just bringing the Queen
out this is looking at least from a very
practical perspective very difficult to
defend for white you know within the
context of a blitz game yeah it does
feel easier to play for black because
the King safety the King on f1
really going you were joking about King
G one king of Shu Qing eg3 but it
actually might go to h2 just that way
rook on h1 because active but I would
think a rook lift rook h3 in the near
future just to do something with the
Ruby can't sit here forever f6 now looks
like it might win a piece because the 95
and bish ones you have are under attack
you know that John's going to think
about that but watch out for Knight to
d7 for King the Queen on b6 and the rook
on it faith you could also consider 19
g6 in some variations but of course 97
with the immediate hitting the rook
hitting the Queen
yeah and that's actually quite an
annoying quite an annoying threat I've
been thinking about a six for John but
I'm not a big fan of that he goes for
Ruby eight he stops the threat of 97 no
longer comes to the fork that actually
might be very very sensible now I think
f6 is a very very big threat the bishop
on b5 is also very loose it's only
defended by the Queen so all of
Lawrence's minor pieces are kind of
loose in the center
how does he resolve all of that maybe
Bishop c4 but then f6
yeah f6 is well actually Bishop c4 f6
and I take g6 I will take your pony 7
because your knight on d5 is pinned so
perhaps that's actually a tactic that
Lauren should be looking at here and the
bishop on c4 can just I want to take any
5 to take out c4 which actually just
might be the thing that hurts white the
most because Bishop e5 d5 rook takes e4
and I followed with Bishop a6 your king
is on f1 yeah very nice sight see and
that's another reason why John prudently
decided not to hurry with a move like a
6 because that Square could be reserved
for the bishop so another idea is Bishop
d3 getting ready getting ready to
sacrifice your piece because I want to
take your pawn on g6 with my bishop
Queen takes h5 and try to check meet you
over here on the Kings side so a Bishop
d3 hangs the d4 pawn it's a variation so
it's getting very tricky he started King
to g1 and he's willing to allow f6
much like a cowboy in a Western is going
straight in the direction of the bullets
f6 what is he intending maybe Knight
takes c6 ok 97 but now Queen d6 I guess
he wants Knight c5 yeah
very tricky that actually induce a big
weakness on blacks King side and if this
95 idea works
it helps white chances a lot the bishop
on g7 looks silly over there rook takes
d7 but Bishop takes d7 hitting your work
on the CA square but maybe that's a
practical chance for black rook d7
Bishop e7 f g5 Bishop c8 and some kind
of Bishop c8 I have three minor pieces
for your two rooks and thought the King
on g1 is the happiest piece either
mm-hmm I like that a lot
and those positions you know three minor
pieces for a queen three minor pieces
for two ropes very difficult to evaluate
also because the ropes and that's
exactly what John goes for I also like
his time management he's leaving himself
enough time okay Lauren's throwing in a
check oh he wants to go h g5 rookie
tried and mate this King but Knight f4
the nine-to-five dream and actually
Queen e6 check I would try to trade the
Queen's off it's a busy check because if
we go back just a few moves oh I'm sorry
first I had I think that's a huge
blunder but continue no I was just
saying trading the Queen's and then
taking the rook seemed a lot better
because you get into an endgame where
the two rooks can try to take on those
minor pieces here you see what the
Queen's on the board and not the g2
square and the bishop on e6 x is just
hanging
I think Lawrence is completely lost now
much like Don Quixote he's emerged from
all those battles and all he's facing
our tilted windmills Knight f4 for king
the Queen the bishop defending h5 we see
the shake of the head I think this is
just resigns for Lawrence I just don't
see a way to prolong this game um how
about yep I got nothing you can't even
put a queen on d3 for instance if you
can go Queen d3 and then the knight took
on e6 just for argument's sake can I've
rook aged five
now here after Queen III just scoop up
that Bishop you are up three minor
pieces just for one rook and of course
Lawrence is going to regret not taking
the rook on c8 definitely I'm not sure
what the evaluation would have been then
I mean it's understandable that he was
writing the heatwave he was writing that
confidence but he played eight shakes g5
fairly quickly and those ideas that
hinge on a very unusual mechanism like
rook takes h5
especially with so many pieces on the
board you just got a double triple
quadruple check that because one tiny
reputation and everything collapses just
as it did indeed it props to jump
Bartholomew for you know sacrificing a
pawn playing it's sort of anjaan like
style and coming out on top so both the
players we're thinking about game one
Lawrence play the technically very
precise game to win an endgame over JB
now JB taking the tactics to Lawrence
what is going on is this role reversal
Thursday well what did we see yesterday
evening we saw Teddy Coleman winning one
time scramble after another so who knows
what's gonna go down here and Lawrence
wisely resigns I mean nothing else left
to play for one-one-one-one it is and
Lawrence going for a French if John
Wardley for it of course John plays c4
he's a d4 player pretty much through and
through and I'm 93 are we gonna see a
six again from Lawrence is he going back
to life this time there should be seven
sort of another classical approach or c6
Bishop d6 is a very very solid system
aiming to of course trade off the darks
quick bishops this is I mean in my
experience playing this with white I
found it very very difficult to prove an
advantage you for white but I'm sure
John has study this now g4 is a sharp
move John chooses a slightly more
peaceful approach bringing the knight to
g3 and probably the Bishop to d3 how
shock to you that John did not play
extremely I I mean for John to choose a
positional continuation Robert I think
that is first I think we should pause
the match and honor this with a moment
of silence and now 9006 by Lawrence H
for so I was about to say we saw h4 by
Lawrence in the previous game which was
kind of artificial it was just like
trying to make it attack out of nowhere
here h4 isn't quite alpha zero like it's
more positional because so I'll go ahead
no no even I wasn't gonna say anything
of substance it's okay that's what I'm
here for I don't want you to say things
of substance no I was gonna say we saw
h5 from some world champion like figure
on move 3 we see h4 here soon anyway we
might see one h4 or to h4 I mean why
don't we just throw those moves in at
the start just to scratch that
that we can play some real chess I would
be here for it and now the pawn h4
people are looking at that part like
wait it's not just gonna be a goner
what's the night moves from f6 and well
it
what about 98 I can't go full greedy and
just win your homage for why not I mean
that pun you know that's why often times
in the caro-kann when you do play h4 h5
you don't castle short that pawn becomes
weak Laurence starts by immobilizing
Jon's Queen side upon minority now that
might backfire because that pawn in a 4
now needs to be defended but Knight b6
here seems like a sensible way of doing
that and then I think he can play 98 yes
Knight b6 the downside of that move is
if the B file open to be the knight in
front of the pawn on b7 so it can become
a target he plays Queen a5 which makes
the knight move from f6 less potent
because the porridge for can actually be
guarded more easily and if I am Johnny
I'm free on Bishop g5 just to try to pin
this net there it is pin the knight f6
protect the pawn preemptively on h4 and
for yeah I was thinking about that and
then port f5 of course now that black
doesn't upon h7 we've seen you not you
now you've done yeah but you've done
this too
we've seen the players in various
matches go after the fee and kettlepot
rupture by trying to just hammer it away
chisel down and f4 f5 not only hits this
pawn on g6 but threads to open up the F
file for rook sitting very pretty on f1
indeed and you know you mentioned
yesterday Robert that you know your
lifelong friends with Teddy and so you
allow yourself a little bit more
roasting I've been friends with John for
many many years we've taught together at
many camps so I'm gonna allow myself the
liberty of roasting him a little bit
more than and that of other competitors
so you know for John to play F for the
stars really really need to align me
because he's gonna look at that onon e3
he's gonna determine that it's weak and
you know that's that's asking a lot so
here he decides to play completely on
the other flank a4 I actually don't
dislike what he's doing he can double on
the B file that punim p7 starts to look
a little bit uncomfortable it really
does and a problem for black is where do
you
is belong tonight would love to go to e4
but you look at that square White has
two knights covering it so that would
just lose a pawn and if you play Knight
to b6 going after the a4 pawn exactly
what you said happens rook F to b1 and
the b7 pawn is far more vital to this
position in the a4 pot because the b7
pawn is the start of a pawn chain so if
the 7 collapses then c6 becomes weak and
now 94 by Lawrence which is offering a
bishop exchange and there you see John
capture and now the rook on e7 protects
b7 so now this Knight and d7 can move
out the way and then you don't have to
touch the b-pawn and make the C pawn
weaker yeah that's a nice harmonious way
of defending and at the same time
bringing some pieces into the other
flank that night on g4 is very annoying
now needless to say it cannot be
dislodged with f3 because the e3 pawn is
once again incredibly weak and it can
simply be captured John going for the
Queen trade if we need to and that
serves two purposes lessens the impact
of pieces on the Kings side and also
reinforces the attack on to b7 pawn I
like it I really like that move in
actually the night on g3 is the problem
piece we've talked about this so
frequently now upon three squares away
from Knight dominates that night this
pawn on g6 is dominating the night on
the g3 with the help of the pawn on d5
taken with the e4 square so if Lawrence
had captured on e 2 then the G Knight
were taken on each 2 then going to f4
then to d3 then it's a c5 that sounds
like a long trek but in reality there's
very little black can do to stop it and
once the night lando square like c5 or
if you have to stop me from playing like
to c5 you've a very defensive approach
from blacks point of view instead of an
aggressive one absolutely and I think
Laurens doing the right thing by
refraining from the Queen trade once
again Jon's gotta find consistently find
new ways to apply pressure on blacks
position I'm not sure Lauren says a
clear plan of improvement in his own
right but maybe something like 96 I
would play Queen c7 hope that John mrs.
Queen h2 is grim well that's quite
sensible too and after night of 4 there
maybe then you could play 96 once again
hoping that he takes on e6 and there's
exactly what he does and he's also
reinforcing the b7 pawn so just in case
now this rook 87 can move
of its square so I like this move Queen
c7 in g3 you know John's worried about
sacrifices eventually on the III square
and if F takes III the G coupon becomes
a target many too has to stay put for
the time being and I'm looking at this
night on that face not doing anything
down yet I'm thinking 96 which threatens
both pawn to g5 is an option but I'm
looking at make g7 night at five and
then I'm really going to sack town on e3
I like it and as you pointed out that
night only to really holding the world
on its shoulders John's pressure looked
very formidable on the be souldn't one
but now it's sort of evaporated we have
a piece on the Queen side I really like
this maneuver 97 95 I just an e4 by
Johnny's trying to change the course of
the game interesting decision out deed
64 he plans to take with a night and
then maybe crash through with d5 his
pieces from a purely positional
standpoint might be better place that
rook on a7 is awkward oh but by the way
D takes a 494 maybe there's rook takes a
4 maybe maybe I should watch what I say
that rook could all of a sudden jump in
via the a file yeah you keep the corner
of your eye on this pawn at all times
and with this pawn structure f7 g 6h 5
I'm looking at the dark squares and you
know that Lawrence is thinking what if I
get my Knight kicked away from the g4
scored a timely f3 could be devastating
for Lawrence to me
so you know I wouldn't play after E
without really figuring out okay my pawn
g3 is safe and sound it's not too
weakening I do have Knights an e 2 and E
for covering the g3 square so f3 is a
possibility just to land mine item v f6
square yep it is and and that 92 once
again sort of in the in the shadows but
it's doing that hero's duty of defending
g3 this is a very critical moment for
Lawrence notice the time situation this
time he is the one feeling the heat he's
got less than a minute and King f8 he's
running away from anything we've seen
that in the last game with King out fun
now he's doing it with the other side
and Queen c3u and night to see there I
was in queen c3 trying to front of d5
and made on h8 but this night now d5 is
very tempting and look the other Kings
on f8 f3 the knight can move away
without Knight f6 coming with check
winning the rook on d7 so that's another
thing to keep in mind as like
mentioning the f6 square yup and that d4
pawn attained so I feel like John should
just throw his ships into the center of
the table and play d5 because embarking
on sort of passive defense with them
something like rook before it just
doesn't feel in the spirit of the
position with that being said you know
maybe you look before holds on I would
just play d5 very quickly and my
intuition tells me that white should
have something here all of his pieces
are coordinated that came on f8
certainly not out of the woods and John
does have a lot of time he's got a
pretty sizable time and vintage at this
point so he's being smart to use some of
it right now because this is a critical
decision it changes the entire nature of
the game he plays roof before shocking
that John would take the safer approach
and I put safer in quotes I was worried
there about 95 and 96 t4 actually but no
matter Laurens decides to reinforce the
pressure straightforwardly with Queen
dat this is also quite worrisome how do
you protect that pawn and c5 is a threat
oh I just looks to you one I guess but
van your move c5 comes with great effect
at Queen on g3 just completely in the
way and pinned and a huge liability so
completely five just sacrifice the point
that pump plug the hole yep give black
and I slave on i goes 92 and maybe it's
okay you're 95 move still is tempting
isn't it it is in the 94 and then math
simplification on the t4 square tonight
after a check picks off the Queen I know
it's a bit different now because the b7
pawn will be hanging in mini very 95 now
though that's a 400 gosh 95 net he's
just missed that fee wait next 965 now
Knight takes e5 for white
oh and 92 22 and he gets out of the pin
and a chance emitted by Laurence wow
that was a fork that was just a villain
after Knight takes d4 there still is 95
isn't there max after Knight takes d4
here 95 maybe some 96 check and Queen C
3 but moot point now it does take on c5
junta's and mrs. opportunity so nice all
maybe better
I don't know but 92 created rook t2 is
something that I'm looking at like hey
your f2 pawn but after that fate is
worrying me of course I mean the king is
not happy after rook t2 is queen up 313
a glazed check and rookie 7 Lawrence now
Queen f3 95 Queen f6 can be considered I
feel like John Scott the much easier
play here it's hard to make a mistake
Queen B 2 also merits consideration
look at his pieces all of a sudden
they're very well coordinated I wouldn't
count Lawrence Alan White's King is not
entirely out of the woods yeah 96 check
is the threat here 96 ones the Queen 96
exactly when the Queen but that might be
a smart sacrifice all things considered
96 I take a give up my queen on c8 and
then I've broken a knight for the Queen
and the white king is actually not safe
this is where you see oh I don't know
the trait on that square that in like
that yup now the pawn flies off still
some kind of play though Robert for
black rook t1 check it's not over yet it
is not over I would go King GA just
prophylactically to get my king safer
because I'm worried about Queen see
through there is like eg and unfortunate
I'm running out that pot has reached a 6
and ot 6 a 7 you're not in time to avert
e6 fork f6 and Queen c64 k 7 hey if that
night can help you attack that pawn you
win the pawn true and that is a drive
black and consolidate in that position
Jon wisely stopping nice c4 oh here
comes my b8 Queen b7 other decision I
was thinking of some cute stuff but but
still not still not a draw because my 7
rookie 7 over 700 that was winning
that's winning - this is what you would
make the mistake of trading too many
pawns here
because this can be a fortress indeed
white displays this we've seen the Queen
e5 though making an easy job for Jon and
Lawrence yeah Wow the shake of the head
that was quite defensive finale there
and Jon he's got a count as lucky stars
that 95 move you know not to give
Lawrence too much flack but that is a
move that he should see especially after
you know what he delivered in the
pregame interviews I'm gonna bring up
the analysis board really quickly just
to show that while this new game gets
underway because you're absolutely
correct that there's 95 tactic for King
the Queen and the rook I'm gonna go all
the way back in time to find that moment
here we are
where
you look went to Seaforth there is a pin
down the D file 95 simply wins in
exchange attacking the Queen attacking
the rook
there's no way to capture this 95
because the queen is on priest so a
missed opportunity by Lawrence several
more after that but John converted very
nicely actually liked his technique for
the most part in that game and now he
has a two to one lead he lost the first
game so a 1-1 now he's at plus 1 and for
Lawrence you have to stop the bleeding
you cannot go on until tear because this
match can get out of hand if John
Bartholomew has a lead in the match he's
such a solid player I don't really see
him giving that up did Lawrence's late
on his payments he's got to pay the
Trent and you know he's just got to sit
down calm down when this next game but
again he's into what I would say are
uncomfortable waters now this is he's
not losing upon for no compensation he's
sacking it he's got the center he's got
the pressure John definitely thinking
about Bishop before check here and I
deliberately Robert notice what I did
there I talked as much as I could after
that terrible pun so that people would
immediately forget what I just said I'm
actually a little excited because I
liked the pun I was gonna compliment it
but one pun that you liked I had to wash
away with sentence after sentence of
meaningless drivel yeah I mean your
self-deprecation is at all-time highs
and I feel a little bad I feel like I've
contributed to that so I'm gonna take it
back a notch and that was actually a
good one I approved of that so there
look look at these words of affirmation
that you're receiving from me it's
because we had such a fun time last
night compensating Teddy versus levy and
I know this is also going to be a very
exciting match so I think we're at a
good friendly vibe right now dunya don't
be so hard okay
Touche Touche my friend and I just out
of the corner of my eye said Lawrence
perform some gymnastics on his chair I
think he's he doesn't seem very happy at
the outcome of this and I don't think he
should be because John not only to see
how the extra fun Lawrence doesn't have
much to show for it the center alone is
not going to guarantee full compensation
for the pun or am i miss reading this
position but you also know that JB
doesn't like even the thought of being
attacked so when I see bishops and d3
and d2 lined up at the black King side
Oh where's that King going if I go to
castle
will there be some kind of e 5 and then
putting a knight on e4 and sacrificing
on h6 that sounds very far-fetched
especially in the current position but
it's not that easy for black to obtain
activity for the pieces you have to get
a c5 break in order to feel really happy
by your piece placement but c5 runs the
risk of just losing the pawn back in
which case well you're up a pawn now
it's even amount of pawns you still have
things to worry about it I think
Lauren's will consider on d4 just to
stop any idea of c5 yeah I like before
clamping down on the c5 square White's
gotta watch that before Ponton himself
because if he loses that bond then you
know things basically fall apart but
that pawn is not gonna be easy to attack
because not only does the bishop guarded
if worse comes to worse whites Queen can
shift over to be two as well I do think
that John is threatening c5 Laurence
doesn't seem concerned about it he
throws before to the wind one about c5
here what does he want d5 sort of Moran
style that's exactly what I was thinking
of and when you saved Moran style I
didn't know if you're just putting an
accent I'm or if you talked about
the opening Iran but in this case I
think I'm talking about you I'm talking
about the opening no I know I know my
friend you don't have to clarify we're
on the same page here but the king is in
the center so what Lawrence's idea is
he's throwing caution to the wind he
wants to sacrifice another pawn open up
the e-file and JB says not so fast and
plays d5 but I see a big problem with
this position from blacken and what I'm
looking at is if I do get a Bishop e7 or
Bishop d6 and just stop this pawn and
Castle I can't play g6 very easily
because my pawn is on h6 and we'll be
hanging in the case that I Castle so I
think that black will not be able to
castle for the foreseeable future and
that is surly not JB style definitely I
think that's very good observations that
pawn and h6 might seem imperceptible and
important it is very important with that
being said let's say John yeah that's
what I was thinking g6 in the neither
Bishop d6 or Bishop g7 and council short
wait who feedback signs
d6 you're not casting short yet because
your point eight-six is hanging right
true so let's say Bishop g7 and then
Castle short how is white going to
respond here while he
a couple of Tempe before black completes
developments so the Bishop of g7 makes
see if I feel a little bit weaker but
not so weak did I feel like I can take
advantage of I kind of want to pile up
on the e5 pawn and I wish my knight can
move from f3 so I could play pawn to f4
all right f2 to f4 right now would be an
extremely good move
opening up the board but I have to my
knight out the way so is Lawrence and go
for knight eh for sac a piece with night
at five and go for an all-out attack on
the Kings side I could see him doing
that I could also see him playing
something more peaceful like Queen c1
after Bishop g7 trying to stop castling
although that just doesn't seem to quite
have the desired effect
um John is definitely thinking I think
about where to position the bishop now
maybe he's gonna go Bishop d6 and
basically say you know what my King's
pretty safe in the center for the time
being what the center being closed the
danger there as you pointed out Robert
is something like nine h4 followed by
other meta fiver f4 the center is torn
open very very fast and John can come to
regret keeping his King in the center he
decides g7 in access on the show online
Bishop d6 let's say I go Queen C I'm not
quitting one yet I make some move like
h3 or king of fate I go Queen c1 to
attack the h6 pawn and you think that
your king is going to go to g7 a
protective den idea is like Knight age
for a really powerful where I'm sacking
a piece of f5 with a check to your King
on g7 threatened to win the bishop on d6
the pawn h6 so if it came were to go to
the g7 square in those variations then
I'm really looking at the Knights act so
that's why John smartly plays Bishop g7
castles his king and now after Queen c1
I think that he'll just like king to age
7 and say you're not getting this pawn
buddy it's well protect you now I don't
like that movie age 3 by Lawrence I
think that was way too slow if he was
planning to play positionally at least
go Queen c1 immediately forced janta to
sweat a little bit to work on on having
to Castle to make some concessions such
as h5 which would have weakened the
chief five score now as it stands
Lawrence may be still preparing up for
but you know the medicines gonna be
worse than the disease there I just feel
like John now has very firmly the upper
hand he's also thinking about Knight g4
as an option just to say hey come on
take me on g4 open up the H file and
they
fathers and little anything right now
but that's a very common theme
especially the Spanish where you play
Knight g4 you take with the H pawn and
you just say you're your pawns are
immobile on the kingside and I have this
more aggressive attacking structure for
white yeah I actually like night before
that's a very annoying move to deal with
for John after Knight g4 I would say
Knight takes e4 because you don't want a
lot my my knight sac do you 94 h5 going
Knight age 6 and for King h7 I'm going
night on 5 I'm second is you're gonna
let me sack my knight Don you just let
it happen buddy know what Robert
because we've decided to be friendly I I
would have let you do that in the real
game let's just let the record show but
Lawrence rook F t1 he's keeping his
options open for the time being I
suppose he's not in a huge hurry with
the center being closed
what do you make of his approach here it
also has about to give the deep ok
Knight g4 absolutely it feels like a
must there it is king 87 probably and
then can I plead for my knight on that
front but I actually don't know if the
sacrifices work right now I like to make
them eat because he can go to d6 the
knight is an excellent blockading piece
and so from the d6 square it covers f5
and stop any kind of d5 to t6 for white
so in 98 actually seems like a very good
move
yeah and that's I can feel sort of meta
5 net inching all these temptations but
you gotta rein it in and actually choose
something I like Queen c1 after age 599
structure looks very flint oh wow
very brave I'm still looking at 93 dis
to go nine to five absolutely but 93
there's 96 after Bishop g4 it I guess I
can just move my rope and protect this
night but somehow this Queen on h4 feels
like it's in kind of scary territory
yeah I mean Laurens now both of them
basically under a minute that Queen 98
for when I first saw that position of
the Queen I assumed Lawrence would have
some way of trapping and he goes King
age 2 very measured response what is the
idea of this move I guess John is gonna
follow up with 96 and ask him that very
question
yep maybe he wants that for I don't I
think drastic measures are required
because John
not gonna sleep on this forever he's
either gonna play out five himself or
he's gonna play c4 Laurens does not have
a millennium to orchestrate you know
some sort of kind of play like a king
size and the time situation is one we
should call attention to because right
now John was 35 seconds and we like his
position more and more I think
objectively he has a fantastic position
but in a time scramble it can go either
way
but I like the flexibility of blacks
position now you have three different
pawn moves coming up you have h5 f5 or
c4 nasty 4 comes with a tempo and what
is the idea c4 Queen a3 is getting
tricky over here saying hey take my
bishop on d3 I'll take your knight on d6
maybe he is although even at the end of
that line somehow let's say c4 Queen a3
cg Queen d6 in the night c5 whites Queen
I'm not sure if that's a blessing or a
curse we're at five with the King on h7
and a bishop on d3 that's just scary
move to play
hey guys eat four and next he closed the
bishop down right and white has this one
window of opportunity I don't see what
he can do a four is a big threat
John just driving in that wedge now we
should have four played Bishop f4 it the
tact is 96 there it is now everybody
maybe no but that Bishop t6o then we're
gonna once hangy for free
oh my goodness he could just take it but
then six night at five he gets not
scared right like he's just look I don't
I don't think he saw it honestly but
maybe there was compensation there now
he was right before and then 9fg will
check yep he's just been just winning
but there's something that is invoking
fear in his brain about playing f4
because a bishop on be one of the King
on h7 yeah and Jon converting this sound
lame and this is still winning that
night on g3 pens he's just mowing down
all these bonds I just don't see the
activity jokes but Queen c7 drumming yes
taketake on c6 of five rookie six oh my
god six but there's some night at five
tactics maybe you're right and we need
to know that doesn't work hmm oh gosh
what now is going on here Rock h6 no
Knight of 200 wins the queen in the game
I mean they're moving so quickly I'd
even know it was happening either
I was expanding for tactics I heard you
sing Queen H no which you want I quit
they think quite you know appealing
maybe rook takes h6 check was a good
practical chance but why just didn't
have enough firepower there yeah I'm
gonna show that game on the analysis
board really quickly because it was a
tactical battle towards the end there
and it felt like Lord's had something
because the King on h7 was very barren
and I know you were looking at some
Brook takes h6 check King and choose
between age five and the Kingdom Queen
g5 check hoping just when the f5 pawn as
well and actually that looks pretty
devious because if the king ever goes
back to G it's a King h8 quit age 16
Jews Bishop a to check a very timely
moon saying your king is not escaping at
least not without giving up your work
over there so an interesting position at
the end but time scrambles crazy
mistakes happen and at the end there
Lawrence blundered his Queen so props to
JB shame its framing like that I
wouldn't say Lauren's blundered his
Queen as much as JB consolidate
extremely well and then Lawrence
couldn't find a saving grace in the time
travel indeed he pushed and pushed him
off the board he also misspoke I wanted
to correct her Robert he said blacks
King looks pretty barren I was gonna say
blacks King looks pretty Davis but no
that is that ye you know it was
manufactured wasn't it it was it really
was because who's gonna think of Baron
Davis in that scenario and Baron Davis
is awesome and I know your waters fancy
you're reflecting on when they Pete the
Mavs in the first round the big upside
way I know where you're going with this
exactly I get you but the people aren't
getting you right now and what I'm not
getting but live there are people yeah
well I'm gonna speak for the people cuz
sometimes I just you know I just want to
be the voice of reason and say Danya
chill you so can you drivers in them in
this metaphor and you'd be the night
that's gonna come from c3 d4 to the c5
just a stabilizing force you know
telling people what's what and who's who
and that's exactly what I think John is
trying to do and look at Lauren's he's I
think on the verge of full-on tilting
he's lost three straight games
John is hit the turkey and I've actually
bowled with John before it's quite a
good bowler and the 94 coming right to
c5 is this going to be four in a row
it might mean that night on c5 is
vicious that we that just weakness it
hurts to look at it and John I've
observed the pattern of him drinking
coffee I feel like after every victory
his sip of coffee at first it was a
small sip and then it was a vigorous
swill it was just he was savoring that
coffee at the ends and I think that
that's how modest John is that is his
form of celebration
more coffee into his veins more caffeine
this is looking quite alarming for
Lawrence indeed his bishop is about the
attract in the center of the board
because if white can play E for which if
you allow me to I will that Bishop has
very few retreating squares the c6 court
being the only one and the knight and
the bishop are competing for the same
square this matter before has one safe
retreat c6 so now a 396 c4 but then the
d4 pawn is hanging so but not right
getting tricky
no rush maybe a 396 Bishop b2 uh-huh
gosh or Bishop b2 immediately yes I like
you should be to leave at nighttime
before some of you may be saying wait a
minute before it looks kind of
threatening it's not advance square but
it's actually more vulnerable to attack
than it is aggressive in nature and then
I has nothing to do over here so
castling kingside says getting my king
to safety no Knight see two checks
nothing of that nature
I can play a 3/8 maybe I'll play Bishop
a3 male played Bishop d2 I have options
so let's just keep calm and continue
pairing off blacks pieces because bucks
even have a threat you have Keep Calm
guys drink my Starbucks and no just got
them got a nice position here let's try
to convert this should be to Bishop a3
the problem here is it's hard I mean
practically speaking maybe why it's
advantages not even that vast although I
actually think it is it's just hard to
make a mistake here for white basically
any generally improving move is gonna be
a good one it should be to rook c1 so
many of these improving moves Lauren's
constantly gasping for air here it's
just so hard to play this position with
black you're saying you don't like this
Brooklyn 87 I love it I think I will
if I were marooned on a desert islands I
would need only the rook on a7 to be
happy for the rest of my
I don't see how their routes getting in
the game and of course a good
co-commentator but we'll get to that
later
well what would the d4 pawn John not
worried about that one kind of coffee is
he drinking I guess this is so
overwhelming oh there's no way Lawrence
can survive this
so b54 what's the response after we
trade PSN before is it Bishop b2 than e5
I mean I don't see would would not
survive that position I mean I don't
exactly see well first of all rug d4 but
should be - and Bishop takes h8 promises
to me at least huge compensation for the
pots that's at a minimum I'm sure that
John is more than that though I see what
you're going your Bishop b2 Queens e5
Bishop takes H Aiden
yeah you're absolutely right the two
bishops are very strong the king is in
the center of the roof still on a seven
not doing anything so that looks good
and it feels like there must be a way to
take advantage of the pin but if there
isn't and he takes any but I think it's
a very smart decision it is by John
because it's so tempting to try to pile
up on the pink piece but if black Ravens
by e5 and knight c6 and then Castle
kingside
me King safety is just so important the
bishop wants a plant itself on f6 play
rook d1 go for a checkmate down the D
file yeah and it's something that you
know the computer might frown on this
but you have to also understand the time
management very very prudent by John
leaving himself over 2 minutes the rook
on his own black is saddled with all of
these humongous weaknesses ranging from
his King that's gonna be stranded for
the rest of the game to the dark squares
to the light squares to his
discombobulated thesis defending this
will require Herculean precision and you
know Laurens a little bit tilted to
begin with this is gonna be a very very
tall order for him I just don't really
see any good ideas because Queen d2
hitting the h6 pawn is also gonna be
annoying if you move the Queen away from
c5 Queen III hits the rook and i7 hits
that h6 pawn so pretty much in every
variation that I'm looking at there's a
problem this h6 pawn and more to the
point the dark squares you have the dark
square bishop from the white side black
does not and I don't know what to do
about this Bishop on the edge rook on a7
and then um before
we're not coordinating very well not at
all and I mean something like C 647 and
just looks so miserable I mean C 683
tinnitus trapped as he as you mentioned
earlier Robert like all of blacks pieces
are fighting for the same resources with
the same two miserable squares and even
if he puts them on those squares they're
still miserable so this is just hard to
look at and Lauren's trying his best
he's tenacious I like the move Queen e7
maybe trying to get c5 in what should
John do here to tighten the screws as
maximally as possible maybe Queen III
yeah he's moving for the pawn I was
actually thinking about a 3 instead of
Queen III because a 396 and E 5 and I
plant my Bishop on f6 that's not going
to be fun for black either and I like
this though I mean everything looks good
so here's options and he chooses this
one because I guess II 5 Bishop f6 is
coming at some point whether you like it
or not
yeah and Bishop g7 Queen 8 she had
another idea I mean not only to see
established material equality more
importantly he paves the way for
absolute and crushing and filtration now
Lawrence also down at MIT at all o'clock
Eve 5 okay actually sort of like that
move 8 you derive maybe H 5 looks good I
mean everything is looked at of g7 it's
just hard to make a mistake here for
wait we talked about this at the start
of the game these huge positional
advantages it's so debilitating to play
against them and someone like John very
very good at handling them as well
he's trying to take away the Kings
escape squares
I don't know but 92 94 I like that and
then the e4 pawn is hanging and then the
White King gets in some trouble that
feels like 87 no I'm agreeing with you
of course that the black king is not
going to be so happy
it takes that Pawnee for is he just
trying to run King da King c7 and one
rookie one yeah f5 Wayne takes c6
yeah I'm even f3 right yeah I mean the
bishop before is very much a daredevil
move but you know Lawrence is flowing a
little bit too close to the Sun here and
there we have it the Queen g6 Bishop f5
the wheels are
coming off whichever way John plays and
the run tha it's a hero it looks
funny over there but it's actually
really helping out and there are many
moves here that are good Queen b6 Bishop
fix at five is a tactical move
if jb sees it you can even trade Queens
and take on e5 but I definitely wouldn't
do that yeah 93 there even without 93
I'm just looking at an end game where
the C pawn becomes past so Queen what do
you think is a queen d6 hitting I like
Whidbey six actually because that hits
not only you know makes contact with the
rook tying down blocks Queen but also
threatened Queen B in and Queen c5 now
very important to find a precise square
Queen e6 checked maybe Queen seven Queen
C a check and then you cannot block on T
eight because of Queen 65 is discretion
they are Queenie six to one of those you
know hitting squares in both directions
ecig sumi-e six hits c8 and g8 and so
the black Queen becomes overwhelmed
quite quickly so Queen e6 check it looks
very good what else do you thinking
right here you could have taken on c7
John does just that though because now
though one last important moment but
Bishop takes f5 all of whites pieces
stream and I think Bishop f5 is just
resigns Lawrence will not resign a plane
move a night c2 I'm guessing after the
first of all John's gotta play it maybe
he's worried about rook c7 there Oh
route c7 but especially six that's
Bishop f5 is the sort of move you play
intuitively because there are so many
pieces around blacks King you've got a
trust in the the natural laws of test
rook e8 whoa what does white to there
rookie that was nice was that will be
philosoph ale John there I don't know
they failed all of us and you know if
you're feeling John Bartholomew you're
feeling all of us indeed now Queen GA
this is so mobs off of everything rookie
for there's a bishop on h8 and it just
you know hasn't moved in a long time but
it's helping out and chillin sipping on
a margarita it's just like why not
Bishop f5 this king is about to find
itself a checkmate so any kind of
grouchy for is nice after rook t1 check
you've your king h2 it's the one final
thing right you don't
go into diagonal and see some checks
happen but the position was so
completely winning for a John that
Lawrence threw in the towel and right
now John has won four straight games he
start off with a loss and all of a
sudden it's been all John Bartholomew
not surprised that John is in the lead
but definite surprise about how this has
happened me too and Lawrence says he's
played experimentally he's played
creatively but in these critical
tactical moments he has underperformed
he has either played too slowly
or he's played a little bit too
experimentally as in the previous game
he's gotta change the lightbulb a little
but I can't put my finger on exactly
what it is that he's doing wrong from a
general standpoint John's just out
playing him yep he is and another chip
of the coffee even more vigorous than
the last and Lawrence is going back for
these Quincy to lines where after the
capture on c4 and he's going to regain
the pawn unless black plays b5 but
that's a very committal decision so JB
going for the solid structure if he does
give up the bishop on f3y will have the
bishop pair but this kind of pawn
structure with bv7 and c6 and f76 makes
the bishop on c4 not quite as powerful
yeah and that's you know in this love
it's easy to look at the center in a
vacuum and say well whites definitely
better he's got that beautiful Center
but that's part and parcel of what the
Slav is all about you have that nice
sort of defensive construction a6 and c6
and you can slowly apply pressure on
white Center that is part of a series of
hyper-modern openings like the groom
felt Kings Indian all of them allow your
opponent to take the center and then you
try to attack the center with your
pieces and so individual Bishop g6 goes
after that pawn on e4 and white pieces
are not developing the Queen side in the
92 and the nf3 fighting for the same
square the bishop once you've worn the
no need to they're fighting each other
the bishop would love to leapfrog that
night and go right to e3 but you have to
move the knight out of the way first
and so mission g6 played for Lawrence
I'm still looking at make c4 and then
Brooke probably being a Knight to e5 at
the right moment I'm thinking night h4
is yeah do I like that issue
and after 93 always to look at tactics
and well 563 95 yeah not sure about that
yeah not he wants open a knight on e4
maybe go Knight g5 but that's very
positionally risky to yield such a
monstrous blockading square on t5 and in
c5 at some moment will trying to
collapse the pawn dating right the d4
points need a protectee 5 but as you're
pointing out h6 is a very good move to
stop any sort of Knight g5 threatening
Queen h7 check and mate indeed and that
neither is sort of a one-trick pony that
idea Knight g5 once it's evaporated
white is left with this huge huge
positional concession that he's just
made yielding that outpost for the night
all right
I feel like Lawrence is it's not that
he's making impulsive decisions but he's
somehow overestimating some chances
under estimating others now c5 can be
considered and that's exactly what John
does wasting no time as you pointed out
Robert pawn center collapses that knight
on d5 is is just incredible
as somebody who plays the elephant
defense not defense the yet what's a
call from the white side the ala pin
against Sicilian the elephant's the Sun
I think it's that basic but I you get
these certain positions often and white
actually still has the potential to
mountain attack this Queen can swing the
g4 the Rope starts an e to protect the
f2 pond but the Queen gets swing over to
the King side a moment's notice and
black has no pieces protecting the King
so that is something that just be
careful about because after Queen g4l
tongue of the King age 7 or King h8 than
the Queen comes of the h-file and at
some point I will take you on a 6
I love sacrifices sacrifices pieces that
are not mine Queen 86 and prevents the
Queen to jump over to g4 because the
rook I need to sing very true that's
that's a good point sometimes you get a
little bit too carried away with the
positional advantages and the Queen side
and you know blacks king is certainly
not not out of the woods now I move like
b4 runs into Knight c3 as well so
Lawrence has to find a way to
disentangle that rook he goes rooks you
too but now rook c8 maybe and that
tension along the C file I'm not sure
that favours white
yeah there are some discoveries Bishop
takes f2 with check if the rook is left
on the C file or if I pile up pressure
on the C file with a rook c7 rook c8 and
then so Bishop takes have to check ideas
will be in the air and yeah you know you
want to play me rook c4 two sweet pieces
on the fourth right but then there's
still that but she fakes have to check
idea so yeah the trades favor black
because white is really banking on the
attack on the Kings side you're not
going to get it in the case of b4 Bishop
back to e7 he goes th - I don't know
Daniel it just feels like Laurence is
trying to will an attack into existence
and it just isn't there yeah I mean King
h2 is very very sensible obviously
bringing the King King out of the pin
but you know first of all John can
consider yeah ninety-seven is an
interesting defensive movies swing in
the night where is he swing it to f5 or
to g6 probably to have five options yeah
he does but I'm not sure about that move
because I like that knight on d5 I feel
like he could have maybe played King h8
and dropped his Bishop back to e7 and
tried to organize as many trades as
possible down the c5 is f2 just hanging
here is there some color isn't there
shag dick for ideas actually bishop
before so I'm giving up the pawn up to
it so a bishop before hitting your
knight hitting your bishop and I don't
see a way to protect both so that's a
funny little tactical shot that Lawrence
is relying on to allow him to finish his
development maybe he will get his rook a
to c1 and then all of sense white who's
first to the C file so something has
gone wrong for John it's gotten 97 Calm
move it did not feel like I was in the
spirit of the position I agree I feel
like if it ain't broke don't fix it that
sometimes does apply to chess sometimes
you try to over improve the position of
your pieces and that's kind of what he's
done here maybe he's got to find one
accurate okay I certainly don't think
he's worse maybe Bishop b6
I know it looks a little bit awkward but
I'm trying to get the heavy pieces off
the board I don't mind that move at all
vision b6 also rook c6 still comes to
mind as a way to double in the C file
and on a safe protected square but
you put a rook on c6 I'm just looking at
a b4 and eventually a b5 I don't have it
available to me just yet but I'm still
keeping that optional lodge the rook to
d8 going for the other open file but
rook c1 now yeah that rook on see it a
little bit loose he could still move his
Bishop back technically but something
about that feels a little bit off and
Bishop takes f2 is still not possible
because Bishop b4 and while leave rook
on c2 can't take on f2 because they were
gonna see one is hanging there's wasting
minutes
you came in r1 either about that not
positive but it looks like white gets
out of that cause so I don't think
Bishop f2 Bishop b4 Roxy - what do you
take with with rook Queen f1 I'm just
should be seven and rook t1 you have
made on see exactly my queen I was just
testing your tactics I I know you've
been a little rusty on those puzzles so
I figured that manufacturer went out of
this game yep and the Queen on e4 is
perfectly placed taking away the Kings
to say escape square we go back to the
live position here and no move yet by JB
after work a to c1 he is now down what
min and a half from the clock and that's
not a good look especially the position
seems to be picking up for Lauren's
Trent it does and the initiative fully
on his side even if objectively speaking
of all Queen b6 playing with some
serious fire here that Bishop on c5
almost out of squares it's only got f2
maybe that's enough though it looks
suspicious Queen h4 comes to mind
keeping the bishop honest to the knight
on e7 but then I'm inviting at night at
five minutes to the tempo so won't work
out the way something looks very wrong
about this move now as Queen a4 with
Bishop a5 to follow also turn in the air
yeah rook c5 there should be three
there's rook takes c1 rook c5 and there
has to be something here there's gotta
be something I just feel it but it
simply must awaiting one's finger on it
it's hard I don't feel like that's it
although it might be just preparing
before hold up my mind for some reason
crashed we're back
wow that was a an inopportune moment for
that's happen but we're back and Bishop
eat one know that that can't be right
that can that is very ingenious Robert I
think he's I don't see a defensive
before and I think neither does John
how about o and B okay well the neck
does protect the rook on c8 so yeah II
for what if a for where does the Queen
joke we'd be six there's before and that
squares defendant twice yeah you're just
trapping the bishop after a four Queen
even still the pressure goes on you
can't move the knight because of before
midnight f5 never takes you 509 84 Huns
hanging you're right my broken c1 is
hanging so Queen should go back to e
maybe I'm blind but a force just seemed
winning on the spot no I think you're
absolutely correct there and so where's
the Queen go now I would go back to e4
yeah because you still have pin along
the C file and then if you see a four
you're happy but it seems like you just
not seen the move eight four right and
after Queenie for John's I'm sure fury
is furiously looking for alternatives to
97 which I personally do not see maybe
rook to c6 holds on because the critical
thing is that rook on C it needs to be
on a better defended square at the
moment it's defended only by its
colleague but that's not enough for
Queen C 4 you can just move the Queen
away and worse comes to worse and Queen
e8 wait a minute but now before before
and just take everything along the C
that was the worst square to put the
Queen on it seems like the rook is now
better defended but in reality the
opposite is true because that queen is
gonna get pinned and we see that AC 3 5
just Queen C 3 exactly you to stay on
the C file and that you've all of your
ammunition Oh what Wow we crazy or his
Laurens crazy
I think it's Lawrence he doesn't quit a
part of this variation quickly check
blacks pieces now we need 7 okay
still though this f2 there right
so black has counter play because you
have to believe me I wouldn't count John
out here take this F to take C 693 turn
a bucks favor okay he's got 93 g2 is the
bishop g1 check which if she was me what
a vicious threat
Bishop g3 is also
threat is even a move here he's dipping
down seven he takes what to do now he's
got no checks
there's no checks oh my goodness you
called it what a reversal of fortune oh
my gosh oh my god that doesn't help
queen c6 only move oh my goodness oh my
gosh dunya dunya dunya dunya dis John
barely concealing a smile here comes the
coffee's if I guarantee you I mean for
Lawrence he must be gutted he just you
know was playing a game where he was at
first maybe at the opening we didn't
love this position then all of a sudden
he doubled the C file should be winning
material and all time trouble Oh
chaos happened and Lawrence was not able
to keep up so the trash talk that we
heard before the match I don't think
it's paying off for that strength I
think it you know glanced off of John
and John is unaffected as ever
actually no sip of the coffee here so
maybe he's changing his habits we see
Lawrence looking hither and thither and
here and there and shaking his head this
way and that way but if that was I mean
so many opportunities one after the
other first day four then before then at
the very ends just queen c3 and queen
succeed I mean that is very
straightforward stuff Lawrence it's got
to be thoroughly disappointed with this
play here for sure and Lawrence coming
out with this Bishop on g7 saying my
bishop should provide me some
compensation but this pawn on d6 is a
real weakness and already I did with
Knight to be 594 come to mind and the
pawn on d6 just fall at any moment here
yeah this is I mean this is just already
looking very nasty right with that pawn
on d6 you can never develop the Knight
to d7 that's one of the problems you
know with the benoni as a whole in fact
on wasn't a weakness everybody would
play the Ben Oni you know that is not a
movie you want to make if you're doing
well tonight c8 just the ultra defensive
move protecting d6 but moving backwards
you were gonna eat that is he not even a
bystander it's not even in the stadium
of this game it's just
just waiting outside because it's not
going to do anything for a while and you
move your Knight to d7 down goes your d6
pawn you move your neck to a6 well your
Knights on the rim it doesn't exactly
look like the most promising piece so
unfortunately for Laurence he's in Full
Tilt John is won five straight games
after losing the first one and he wants
to pick up a six rate and Laurence
making Bartholomew trying to make the
most out of the situation
would you please III hear Queen b3 and
you're not worried about this bet three
because that pressure on d6 outweighs
everything else I really like that move
although if I trade on b3 take on a free
plug rook d8 what I'm trying to say is
the bishop on g7 is so strong that there
perhaps is some counter play in end
games but actually I'm seeing a
reputation very clearly in the case of
Queen b3 takes takes Bishop f3 g of rip
d8 and there's Bishop g5 with Knight f6
check and no space for black and look at
your queen side pieces indeed those
Knights h3 by John I like that as well
because the last thing you're concerned
about is that pawn of b2 but Lawrence
trying to get his Knight to e5 I think
that's sort of his last chance against
95 though John's probably gonna capture
that play Knight f6 check similar to the
line you mentioned definite advantage
for white question is can black hole
that position together and I would
consider after Bishop e5 Bishop e5 even
h4 and we see this fiend cat or pawn
structure just under age 5 and get this
negative 6 check at the most precise
moment possible instead JB goes Queen g3
eventual thing that d6 remains the
weakness 497 probably nice still 96 ah
victims right actually because 93
there's 98 that's actually really funny
line so I can't get my Knight to f5 and
if that's the case then I'm very unhappy
with these developments and III don't
see I mean that's a very strong move
actually resisting the temptation to
take that night which many of us would
do automatically cuz you know black
could play rook e8 here but among other
things John could could play something
relatively slow like rookie 2
and double on the e-file he still has
all of these positional advantages that
not only five alone is it's not gonna
save flex life no well not in 1953
perhaps that's just the pill you have to
swallow here is your pond d6 just an
eyesore and it's going to remain that
way but at least if you take on d3 your
pone doesn't have the bishop pair and b2
pump can be captured
oh maybe 93 inch Queen takes B to just
oh I mean this Bishop on g7 you know you
told me yesterday Donna use that
expression I you know with every I don't
know the exact wording but with every
bad bishop there's a good pawn
Oh bad Bishop's defend good pawns yes
that's it
does that bad bishop defend a good pond
I don't think so
yeah I think it's a bad Bishop defending
a terrible pun and you know we laugh but
it's never that easy to crash through
these positions it's definitely an
eyesore but it's relatively solid I
don't think you want to take on e5
because Lawrence is gonna take a bit
deep on and he's gonna slide that night
over to d6 and he's gonna start
breathing a little bit easier so John's
gonna react precisely here maybe just
Bishop f1 eventually play for f4
dislodging that night from e5
I like Bishop f1 just sing you're not on
e5 it looks like a great piece but as
you're pointing out when y + f2 to f4
I'm just taking the night away and I
want you to take my pony on b2 because
if you take on b2 I've roughly one
rotates p7 and then that rook swings
into an attack so Bishop f1 looks like a
very smart move h4 still comes to mind
as a way to just plow through the black
king side with h5 next and ultimately he
chooses b3 this is just quintessential
jb he's not worried about any potential
f5 he's even happy to second exchange
there this is probably going to be the
last game of the five-minute match so
Lawrence would love to pull some sort of
a miracle here and it might start with
him about five do you think Jon's gonna
know he's not gonna 75 that what is he
planning against f5 exactly uses your
movies
off the a once ago but that Queen a five
come so actually I like f5 a lot and he
Lawrence wants to keep that score open
for the night I'm guessing I know why
2092 to stop night at five because I'll
capture you on at five
but look what John's doing his last year
moves I mean this back to see to
night back to d2 it does feel like he
doesn't have a firm grasp on this
position yup in Lawrence King h8 showing
a little bit of confidence here that's a
generally good multi-purpose move just
tucking the king way I like h4 though
he's stopping any potential g5 threats
and against f5 now there could be h5
softening softening up flexing side
punch structure for sure and the move h5
is always one the black is gonna be look
out for because not only is hg of threat
h6 trapping the bishop especially
picking on h8 but h5 is sent by g5 so
that's why Lawrence you can play move
like Queen Edie eight he will push his
opponent responds and unfortunately for
JB you cannot line the Queen and the
bishop up on the b1 h7 diagonal because
the 95 covers the d2 script but h5 you
know 85 g5 Bishop e5 d5 Queen d3 there's
f5 and all of a sudden blacks pieces
come to life like d4 next and the bishop
is very happy in the long diagonal yeah
I was thinking about something that's
created craziest age v 2g v h6 Bishop
takes h6 queen h3 but number one that's
not in John style number two I well he
may be we've seen all sorts of things
happen so who knows maybe he will play
h6 ripple but oh no h6 bishop beef that
looks very wrong somehow this looks
something about this looks off but I
can't put my finger on it because I
wouldn't touch the age upon yet because
I can keep hd6 open and I keep eight-six
open but for now I want to find a good
waiting like rookie to then write a t1
but is black going to take on a try play
97 to g6
yeah that's what I would be worried
about that's why I thought maybe you can
drive h6 in which he does the problem is
if you take on e5 and then take twice
black is obviously not gonna capture
with the bishop and get checkmate it she
has some f4 80s maybe concretely that
actually does work out for John I'm not
sure he tries it okay
we'll see I'm taking with the deep pond
after route 65 plain corner c6 or
something but then I can't believe is
thinking about this where the move is
possible here okay thank God now Queen
d6 maybe that's what I'm looking at
clinics for exactly the same same
wavelength here but there actually are
some tactics here like Queen b6 f4 I
can't get away with 1955 like I want to
but my whole point was if 95 you take
with the pond then I've rook takes e5 f
takes Bishop takes d5 and your rook on
a1 is hanging on g3 very interesting but
yeah that's actually a very strong idea
so tonight c6 maybe instead of 95
because maybe I'm opening up that
defiles again yeah 95 55 exact 96 what a
move and there's nothing rookie a rookie
8 goes oh no not this way rookie 1 now
he's not even concerned about the
opponent h6 he can drive that rook
further down to e6 the real Kanye is
hanging by the way yes it is literally
he's hanging so 96 was definitely a
better move than they look got those
snappers those are such nice pawns east
6 and D 6 and a 7 and D 7 this is all
just throttling blacks position here
okay but now d7 hangs the e6 pawn and
buddy 7 ok glad for Mike Brooks but by
the way d7 not a move because of Queen
d4 check what another Lawrence he's
gotta go Knight f3 we need 3 Queen e3
which is actually a very very very
strong and if there's no Queen D for
checking this d7 next are there any
tricky things that Lawrence can do like
a knight g8 and after d7 take with the
Ebro can someone take on e 1 yeah it
doesn't work it doesn't because that's a
rookie 7 you could take one Sonny 7 and
then promote I don't even see any traps
the problem is I mean John is very low
on time maybe Quinn age 4 but then
Knight f3 comes in attacking the Queen
defending the rook I was just anything
rookies maybe immediately look he's just
such a sad move Dubrow and I just take
with the deep on Queen d8 check you and
you're gonna be down a piece and then
game true true but I feel like that's
horrible
it's the only way to prolong the game
otherwise that's
and queen for white and then the
position plays itself either way finally
Laurence makes that decision and Queen
da check I would have liked Queen G and
trade up enough they forcing the Queen
trade because this the King on g1 is
actually not a very safe piece and the
fisherman c2 is useless so you need this
we get to d5 and I don't know how
you do that 51 maybe yep
okay now I was thinking b4 Bishop a4 but
perhaps this is smarter getting the
bishop around to protect the White King
and thus vaginas but five seconds up for
John 48 oh they don't like all that it's
another ring any move but I'm not sure
about King h7 that Knight g5 check is in
the mix yeah there was a very good move
between back I don't know why I didn't
take him like with d7 check this is just
time to scramble that's always happening
here and do I take on you one and just
try to draw this endgame no no you gotta
go 43g 395 I'm not sure what's going on
kingi 77 they cage 6 9 of 17 f6 make it
six seven oh my god maybe we hear the
same thing same thing he wins the Queen
of Quincy 7 he said oh it doesn't just
King h6 oh my goodness what can you do
here there has to be something there has
to be something but I don't think Jon's
oh he will create was quit if it was
winning on this definitely on the spot
yeah Queen f8 king g5 the knight of
three Chad f3 d6 exactly and I win your
queen so we were kept looking at these
lines with a queen gave the King a check
and black knew who's behind it but John
time scramble he's up so many points in
the match he probably said I don't see
anything right now two seconds up so
that I could draw so everybody we have a
big lead for John Bartholomew we were
back in a few minutes after the short
break and we returning we'll get into
the three minute portion to see if
Florence Trent can make a comeback
be right back
[Music]
well we be your miss not to talk about
the daily question because today's
question is particularly apt for these
players it is what is the greatest chess
insult you have ever heard and Danya I
have a great story about this but I'm
curious you have any good ones
I have several candidates but I want to
hear yours maybe that'll get my creative
juices flowing let's hear it I guess
this could be applied to non chess as
well but every tape may he rest in peace
what a fabulous player he won a game and
won't name the victim of one of the
fight attacking combinations at Emory
table was able to uncork and he goes
after the game a little while later he
goes I just want to congratulate you for
being on the losing end of one of my
finest victories ever and I'm just like
there are so few people in the world who
could say that deliver it with a
straight face and mean it sincerely and
also not get you know just
absolutely punch in response to that
that type of guy and it was one of the
most hilarious things ever
needless to say his opponent was really
really really pissed off that's that's
very funny I have a small quick one
before the games begin back in the
beginning since the Chess Club in San
Francisco where I grew up playing you
know there was a 1700 who was known for
his Barb's and for you know hazing the
youth who entered the club and I was
around 1400 up a piece against him in
nursing this piece advantage move after
could not convert eventually we reached
move you know 35th move up a piece I
haven't made any progress and I make a
move and he says would you like to offer
a draw and I felt the anger boiling in
my cheeks and at that point I turn
around and I won backgammon ten books
but not quite an insult just pretty
funny phrase you just wanted to brag
about a victory that you had when you're
fourteen hundred that's what imma
getting on the story I did well you know
I had such few victories when I was
fourteen hundred you gotta let me brag
about one of the only ones I had more
power to you buddy oh I have as the
games you can just want very very quick
one one of my first remembrances at the
baguette expose someone
swindled me and he actually wrote 1-0 on
the scoresheet before he won the game
and that made me so angry
I cannot describe how angry I was at
that that was the ultimate slight that
ruined my chess career forever I was
waiting for you to make a joke about how
you know the biggest insult is my chess
play so I was waiting for that I was
honestly a little disappointed that you
are now on such friendly terms with me
that you're not just calling me out and
making me the buddy your jokes but I
sort of appreciate it in a way I mean my
feelings can only take so much I know I
seem like this guy who can handle
anything when you know my co
commentators are delivering awful pawns
and just begging me to stop being
serious but I do want to thank you for
not throwing me under the bus here
mm-hmm
you're very welcome I'm always there for
you
Grandmaster Hess and we seem to be okay
there comes Lawrence and the game should
kick off any moment and here they go
Lawrence of the white pieces he has got
to make a statement early and he has got
to make a statement fast he's got a lot
of time but a four-point advantage is
that's a pretty big one to surmount and
he's got to start early he certainly
does and matches like these are very
difficult because Lawrence won the first
game so you win that first game you like
hey I can do this John's the number one
seed he's really tough but I have a lead
then you lose five games in a row and
you have no confidence in yourself so
the fact that Lord saved that last
position we kind of heard him a little
bit during our break he was not happy
with his play that's clear and this
visual on e6 is this still some kind of
odd theory I suppose he wants to play g6
Bishop g7 or Bishop b5 that's even
better in e6 man this has gone already
wrong for Lawrence look at that Bishop
hidden once he plays d6 that pawn wedge
on the Queen side that phalanx a5 okay
then whoa I feel like Lawrence has to do
this well I've been using on night
movies Knight play f4 f5 and just try to
expand that way but I guess he's gonna
go ahead for i-5 in my line case you
know now g6 I might sacrifice something
that Square at some moment so the
bacteria pawns in h6 can backfire yeah I
mean
Bishop d5 now Lawrence has got to find
couple of very accurate moves to keep
the initiative going as soon as the
initiative is extinguished coupons are
for black again could virtually be over
what about a six for John I'm not
exactly seeing what the follow-up is for
Lawrence there might be Bishop h5 I'm
looking at mr. H five channels yeah I
mean you know me come on what do you
think I'm gonna do if you go g6 we
resign
would you like to draw oh I would love
to you're not gonna take it though so g6
coming and what is the response
I mean sacrificing clearly can't be oh
wait a second waiting with the no I
don't have a follow-up I'm trying so
hard to make the sacrifice happen but
Bishop g6 apps using I can't get my
Queen to g6 and time because the black
Queen will just go to f6 and if I take
on usage the knight FG Bishop g6 King g7
the black King runs to safety well as
they used to say back in the ICC days
resign button is on your right I've
received that a couple of times that's a
pretty good insult that is a but we had
I just remember that and I remember
thinking oh that's pretty witty and I
actually told someone that one time and
I told that to the wrong person because
what came out of that person's keyboard
I shall not reproduce anytime soon it
seems like it's it's it's stuck with you
so clearly it's made an impact and look
this bishop way through Bishop f8 Bishop
c1 if we see a repetition here that
would be hilarious that would actually
be very funny there would be something
comedic about that for sure but I don't
see a way for white to avoid it because
you cannot podcast John's final the
dryads as well this is hilarious yeah
you're right though you cannot allow
this King get to safety castling and the
bishop let's see one is really annoying
because the bishop can't come be seven
so easily we have to pawn to h6 being a
target so you will not be able to castle
so quickly and we see I draw by
repetition with Bishop a3 Bishop c-17s
what a hilarious draw that is that is
one of those original repetitions that I
that I have seen I mean maybe not ever
but definitely in the in the near past
what do you want to go dodge rolling out
the Dutch
what do you think by the Stonewall Dutch
that we're seeing here f5 d5 you've
forgot real over the e4 square but of
course the e5 square is one that why
he's going to take advantage of it and
just generally speaking for people who
may not be so familiar with the Dutch
you look at this position it kind of
looks like black is playing checkers
with all these pawns in the light
squares and that makes the dark squares
weak and on the other hand white can
stop it piece I'm going to eat four with
a pawn to f3 and another thing and done
it of course I'm gonna throw it to you
in a second but if Bishop takes f4
sometimes weapons eat except for giving
yourself double pawns
because if this pawn takes on f4 then I
have a semi-open efile you this really
ugly backward pawn on e6 and as
mentioned I can play f3 to print even
clogging to e4 square so Dania over to
you what's your experience like the
Dutch those are all good points I've
never dared playing the Duchess black I
of course I've faced it with the white
pieces Jon playing very creatively he's
mixing several different plans I
actually thought he was gonna go for f3
for but job trying to switch to the
conventional idea of going c4 now the
issue is he has of course created a
weakness on the B 4 square not
particularly significant at the moment
that night on a - you know as awkward as
it looks it is starting that square so
it's probably about equal I mean I don't
see Lawrence being worse here
c5 can come at some point there we have
it I don't like the way John has played
this I feel like he's mixed up two
fundamentally different plants if he has
that knight on c3 then repair up 3/4 if
you're going to see forth and play
classic wait he's tried to combine the
two I don't know how this is going
maybe he's totally fine I think it's not
really black is doing well because the
netted me two in particular that's a
suspicious piece it's not doing anything
and now comes back to c3 but if we look
at this position you were talking about
this Dona I'm a complete agreement the
be for square what when you look at
nights you think can I get an outpost
what's an outpost a square where pawn
can't kick it and preferably where a
piece can't kick it either and so if I
get a knight to be four and take your
medal II to with my one b7 and we
trade those minor pieces I will have an
item dark square that will can stay
there for the rest of the game now is
that the best outpost in the world no of
course not but it is an outpost
nonetheless and that causes what
some consternation and now he takes on
d4 watch out for the open D file where
there's a queen and for each side and
then two minor pieces for white but I'm
thinking of eventually swing McQueen to
the Kings side for black my pitcher on
b7 wants to line up with the Queen to
deliver a check many threats definitely
now King h8 to be considered followed by
e5 and Queen g6 as you point out the
Queen and the bishop just a lethal combo
996 McQueen say six Knight f4
oh my goodness Knight f4 the other one
just does not go Lawrence's way in terms
of the tactics I wouldn't lose hope here
there's some activity for sure this
Queen and Bishop lined up on g2 I mean
HR though question of 94 maybe Bishop
will 6 o you I knew you're about to do
that I was about to say that you have a
checkmating threat and then you 94
Bishop e6 I no matter how I take on c3
doesn't matter because my g6 is
checkmate sage upon his pin so Donny and
I had the same checkmate on the brain
there is there efore with the idea of 96
check oh my gosh
efore Knight takes e4 Knight 6 Queen g6
Queens using HD 6 roof h3 check and me
and there's some lines where black can
consider sacrificing the Queen for all
these pieces John John the very John
with rook c1 can I go g5 or is that too
much
no I mean I think these situations you
gotta act decisively g5 maybe 92 that
Queen NH 5 is kind of annoying actually
it's hard to dislodge and 92 maybe the
knight can swing to d4 and I would love
to play rook D 6 and D 6 over 2 H 6
through my queen but of course that's
not how chess works so unfortunately for
black you need to kick that Queen out
and rook to Aegis would do so but the
queen of lips it's just kind of in the
way f4 triangle f3 blasting the kingside
hope and he takes once is you know after
himself but then there's no g7 exactly
and that upon an f3 plugs the immediate
diagonal stops the immediate threats but
Bishop takes after he sacrifices are
constantly looming in the air so I
actually from a practical standpoint I I
like Lawrence's position I think he's
got very serious pressure calling that
I don't need to also completely
dominated can't go to g3 can't go to d4
Lawrence has got to be very precise here
but I like his position he's got a big
initiative brew some kind of knight
takes b3 tactics the bishop will be
overloaded protecting the 92 and it's
just something I'm keeping in mind black
would like to trade the bishops because
the metaphor becomes a weakness Knight
afford the rook on the eights hangings
and then a rookie 596 oh that is so
nasty rookie five night g6 the Queen has
to take and the rook is hanging in e5
that looks like a problem so can the
rook go anywhere useful not really
rookie three attacks the f3 pawn but not
ABA let's do enough now just rook d6 is
another follow up potentially trying to
okay John with Queen h4 great prudence
so now the f3 pawn is hanging if you
have to move your night away to squarely
h3 but a nice coming to h5 and now it's
the black King and might get checkmate
it goes Ricky five now for example da
first of all very annoying a little move
I wouldn't call that little mo that's
pretty big yeah pretty big move but now
we could have taken him gone Queen d4 Oh
was that a piece was a nice oh my
goodness miss an opportunity seven
Robert look at the MinnKota beast you
you're inspiring him rookie seven played
finding this wonderful night g6 tactic
and Quinn d4 check there's problems you
get me tonight h7 before you could pick
up this man enough for so it looks like
have worked except for here wait a
second up for rook at 4 or 7 or q7o you
mate yeah I was like I'm trying man I'm
trying but there's no hope
Gina I'm sorry to get so worked up these
tactics just really exciting that's what
I'm looking for I appreciate it
I'm getting hyped because you're getting
hyped the match score isn't you know the
most even of the matches we've seen but
right now JB is just bringing it to
Lawrence and rook 67 is just that once
again take on g5 next this is red with a
John fat look ga checkmate ok guys that
one is good there we go
Wow hey Donnie your taxes wanna fire
that game I mean that the thing is once
you start once you notice the colonel
96 that all the tactics are just
variations on a theme at John finding
rookie 7 I am very impressed at that
that was awesome
and what a game he missed that one
opportunity Lauren stayed to get that
Queen d4 check picking up the night of
that for it after that John has some
Flair that was a flashy way to win the
game and we've seen Lawrence throwing
his King side pond at John he means a
win and you know a draw a loss at this
point plenty of time in three-minute
proportion but the issue is that
Lawrence is not the favorite in Bullitt
either so he can't rely on a comeback
and bullet because John is so strong in
the bullet time patrols so Lawrence
needs wins and he needs them now
actually needs them like three games ago
exactly and he's playing the Joe bobble
London which you know was a guest I
think in the match between who was it
was it Elena and Eric not sure it was
definitely it occurred before I played
myself with white occasionally it's very
interesting system why does expand it on
the Kings side now that's both a
blessing and a curse those ponds under
the right circumstances could also
become very very weak another idea for
black sack couldn't be seven go eat five
as quickly as possible try to blast open
the center but that's actually hard to
achieve okie can't Castle here because
we'd be seven there's 95 trapping the
Queen there's always a larious from the
Queen gets trapped like that but it's a
thematic queen tripping its Queen takes
eight Queen a bishop takes d6 and while
black is certainly better
what has the last four compensation of a
bishop rook and pawn for the Queen
yeah ninety-five has also been the b5 I
mean I just don't see it here is 95 a
bee queen bee five simply King moves
away and there's just no play he's got
to drop his queen back but that's
conceding defeat basically in the
opening night see they're streaming in
that bottom III is weak as well oh I'd
be too is if that's just a double attack
nicely for attacks b2 and it threatens
Bishop takes up for it does and the good
news is I would put b3 here and if you
play Bishop f4 at stake with the e pawn
and just say hey my pawn structure looks
a little weird but having a pawn f4
helps you play g5 and perhaps attack you
on the Kings side I like
flex position I see foreplay - very
quickly by John and how could he not be
confident considering the match score oh
he is and we see Lawrence mouthing some
stuff to himself and I'm pretty sure
he's neither uttering positive self
affirmations nor saying namaste he is
not happy Queen b3 as a tilt above now
it just castles and e5 this looks
miserable why can't even counsel because
of 92 Queen b3 is just doesn't look good
and I don't understand couldn't be just
like b3 this isn't even protect the pawn
on e3 right Bishop f4 is still possible
night 87 John tried to perform surgery
on those pawns with Knight g5 yeah I I
guess but something you had exactly I
guess is a good way to react to that
it's not bad everything's good in a
position like this honestly I would
think about eight eggs p5 here give up
the f3 Knight m3 e92
how you this 92 stuff still I don't know
that's not I'm not totally convinced by
that either
yeah I agree you need some kind of
imbalance if you're Lawrence because
black is just kind of pressing forward
on both flanks
so a b5 just even a desperation feels
like a try here yeah I mean I I'm sure
this is objectively winning for black
but Lauren's spending too much time he's
just gotta mix things up as you say he
has got to mix things up he can't just
sit here and freeze and you can't take
on g5 because Queen takes g5 hits the e3
pawn a second oh gosh oh gosh squeegee
fine pieces going backwards look at them
yeah buddy Russians just Castle give up
that pawn you want to lose them possibly
before but now I couldn't snap out of it
now 23 + b3 I don't like before I think
John is he's trying to have his cake and
I mean just sack that Vanja sack b5 it's
not even a sack you take you three yeah
this this move b4 here in acquit III
played now here comes b3 and then I
don't I still think why can Castle
easily but then after b3 Gordon I have
to pawn up for
I'm trying to push your pieces back and
then finally connect my roofs so John
being a little bit too perfectionist I
would say you know not giving up the
beef iPod just trying to avoid the
tactics and we send this in other
matches right sometimes these very solid
players are fearful of some kind of tax
will imbalance and they play with base E
as the comest most secure move but you
know when you were just playing secure
chess your opponent can actually still
create play nigel is b3 and gives up the
b-pawn so he could have done this right
away and now have five and mg I would
play at five in a second and against b3
F takes G four in a second because the
power of black spaces is such that I
mean with 49 seconds on the clock
there's no way what's defending that
that is exactly what he does go to
Johnny be right to move ethic b3 Oh F
takes you for f4 exactly what I'm
thinking and I would have lost that's
exactly what happens in most of my games
you go for the sacrifice see that's the
thing is you know me I love to sacrifice
the players pieces they're not mine but
I saw f4 as a response to F takes G for
and I was like wait wait wait wait a
second down yeah and I'm still thinking
about Knight F to here and just trying
to play f4 as a response to any kind of
F takes G for yeah I missed that that's
a very nice idea but Knight f2 may be
real kb8
now you've taken me all over the place
now he just takes and it gets let's the
rook and f4 Queen g2 potentially Queen
can park itself on h2 actually but I
like that for more than what I've liked
for what is then you go rook G one night
f2 you know why does she need for check
oh my god you're checking me from
everywhere indeed and okay still why
does in the game I mean this is not over
yet but something like win H do I just
feel like the threats are coming from
too many angles here rook c8 h five
everything yeah rook to d1 is not a
movie you ever want to play when your
king is under attack but Kingdom d1 so
far everything is protected the Queen
tonight sure would have been better
because then the 92 would have been
overloaded Queen up three pins that
night and says hey you're 90 there now
is really under tech medayto
is the only move that i see here can you
just save your knight yeah rope g3
there's
rook c3 I'm all other things yep c3 is
and
that immediately queen c3 queen f1 and
then you win the night only to a check
and then look at it John is just so
alert right now he is incredibly sharp I
mean he started off a little bit sleepy
some you know droopy eyelids but he sat
that coffee and he has been so sharp in
time pressure it's it's been a just
incredibly strong play with just a
couple of inaccuracies but no major
mistakes and Lawrence playing on because
rook do you want be did you want all the
be 30 plants hanging if it be people
we're not hanging one we try to sleep
what is it he's not threatening anything
John down for seconds here's what you
195 34 he got out the Queen gets out
have five what el arias move may f6 me
preside John Rose I hope c1 groups even
threats against blacks king of become
overwhelming and JB and this guy is hot
nails I you know I spoke too soon after
the first game I was like Lawrence just
outplayed John technically this could be
a tough match for for John but you know
Lawrence is a tough competitor here but
the match hasn't seemed that hard for JP
somehow he hasn't even blinked I'm
wondering if he's okay tranquil as a
forest but on fire within yeah he is
just locked in loaded it's mean this is
this is not looking good for once at all
although this opening maybe he's going
Lawrence's way
you know the bitchin 7 your head
luxurious and doesn't inspire confidence
I suppose yeah this in general will you
don't don't worry so much about your
pawn on d6 you feel much happier to play
the Benoni and the Benoni is a very
strategically risky opening because of
this backward pawn but typically this
pawn is on b2 rather than the c3 with an
opponent c3 just feels like Black has
some opportunities to put pressure on
the queenside if you can time it right
but I guess John just to clamp down and
say not so fast yeah I mean something
has gone wrong for John that not only
five well John playing Bishop h2g fall
of these moves are very typical Benoni
moves f5g 5 expanding on the Kings side
that not any 5 has been a thorn in
John's throat before in that last game
and a five-minute segment here black has
that night as well as all of the other
positional advantages so John and big
big trouble here but the fight is still
ahead and in White's position is still
very tough not to crack him and so is
John as a as a defender Bishop b5 a nice
c4 comes to mind threatening Knight b6
and Knight 65 and you know that Lawrence
just wants to play at 40 he didn't get
it he could have played out for us at 86
I actually didn't like a 6 I feel like I
was a bit slow but now after this
capture on your 94th ready Knight b6 and
the bishop
just take it we have so quickly with
rook e8 but now the problem is 95 and c4
black might be slightly better but it's
debilitating when the advantage
transforms from something you were
looking forward to to you know
relatively minor positional event John
decides to let that Bishop go maybe
Bishop f6 now yeah I feel that
and neverkey 4 is coming and I just a
sense of attack yeah a 5 seems like key
things are slipping away here for junk
is that nighttime b6 is gonna be
stranded exactly then I get stuck there
it looks like a great square when you
see Sicilian you know a night or day I
get my knight to be 6 that sounds so
good in theory but sometimes in practice
your knight gets their a can't get out
of there and black is focusing all of
his pieces on the King said watch out
for Queen g7 rook age for Paul in g4
just blasting through and the Kings and
I'm actually not sure how white deals
with it yeah cuz Queen e2 also meets
with the Queen b5 picking off the knight
so even if you want
to backtrack you could maybe 92 is a sad
necessity the problem is it might be too
late
rook age 4 and then G for Knight is cut
off from f3 this this is looking very
grim indeed for John and he plays Knight
b6
Queen g7 idiot boy I don't know also he
can put Queen B 5 I guess but I would
not go cream beef I'll just go please
you seven just go to the Kings side I
think why wouldn't you you're your king
is very safe despite the fact you push
pawns there and rook age for g4 all
these moves feel quite natural and some
cases obvious indeed I would play a four
if I were John sometimes when you're
basically lost transforming the position
even if your moves aren't objectively
good is the way to go but maybe John
isn't as worried as I don't know should
he be worried cuz rook h4 looks mighty
mighty unpleasant Queen up three g4 we
need to G for that H file once it's
opened spells immediate doom for white
what's what's right response may be some
kind of e3 well I'm waiting for you to
take on a tree and then I was gonna go
to g3 plays it right away
and you too again stroke h3 I like it
okay
so row gauge 3 king g2 and black has to
be doing well right I mean sometimes
white is actually doing well despite
losing a pawn station with the pawn on
he I guess he wants an eventual age five
age 4 or enhancing that one as a
battering ram but doesn't look quite as
good well after King Itsuki I go f4 here
and he plays rook g4 bags FF 4 at 4 hero
Chi 3 o PG one clever no no I think I
prefer black oh yeah trust me I'm not
thinking of f4 for white that's yeah I
thought I didn't I can no I'd be said if
that it's it instead of rook g4 I was
saying black playing f4 because the rook
is immune to capture because point you
to his mate and after ef4 rook f4 I'm
just hoping that along the F file I
could cause some problems
Shawn with King takes h3 I mean he's got
to be very careful now rub g3 is a huge
threat but maybe King g2 and oh wait in
g2 rook takes in the day of 60n oh right
he - IG - there
oh my gosh you summer you're surviving
you're in fact you're trading Queens
often maybe you give a check on h3 first
done yeah hx6
bring my work into the game what now
look up six anyway and rook g6 Rick f6
looks pretty good because if I get a
good start
all my pressure on the g3 square H 5 H 4
I mean that also looks good uh-huh
well after H 4 GH oh but then even a
rogue h4 and rook up six homes active
six John h4 h4 what you waiting for
there it is an AG king of one somehow
John surviving but not by much and then
it just GF and yea GF no wonder Joe in
this match yeah yeah so much is
happening here don't kick on f5 cuz
Brooke of 6 it's got a taking go Quinn
h4 and try for some last-ditch counter
play I like that
trying to get to d8 square oh you are
this move the about the way in a
queen bee to check yeah we not alive oh
here's Queen CHS ooh but Jim Sioux
what did you do I think at 6 just to
cover my squares and what's the follow I
was Queen c2 is it just that simple
mission h2 I can't do anything I guess
not well you could no you couldn't I
don't know what they sure you could
resign I think you must resign because
unfortunately quit see a check oh this
Queen here
wait guys taken go king of three you
could was that even route g3 now let me
see a queen up three or three that was
wait for the g3 and he resigns okay I
was made a couple more move okay that
game hurt my head
honestly yeah brain hurts it really does
it takes a lot of time off the clock
though it did but finally Lawrence has a
win to his name and what he hasn't won a
game since the first game of the match
right just a couple drawers mm-hmm so a
second win of the match was going to
feel a little bit better but still he is
down five points and John didn't change
at all like
his facial expressions do not change
yeah they literally when lost you
annoyed you see down by 30 points to see
up by 60 points John is just made of
steel actually don't even think we call
facial expressions was just singular
expression to just one it's the John
John the genius just to focus John a
casual John it's whatever it is it's the
job GQ Man what does John usually say
what were Siamese lines yes this is hey
guys this is John I'm gonna play some
team's candy today oh man oh man man not
my game this game just fly down move ten
it's okay we're gonna we're gonna take
the next game let's play a scandi here
they were playing solid slob here solid
stock here guys I'm just take a drink
drinking my espresso guys all right guys
now I'm doing my Starbucks espresso
let's uh let's play a nice solid slot
here guys all right thank you guys love
it I love it
your John is fantastic and in general I
mean this guy he's good figure on his
chin right now that is the pensive John
look I've never seen before
yeah I haven't been able to do Lawrence
though I've I practiced it right before
the match for like thirty minutes but I
wasn't able to capture any of the I mean
he certainly speaks slowly I can't seem
to understand exactly what makes him
tick you know it's more that I can't
really do it now no can't do Lawrence
you can't I appreciate the effort but
Lords yeah its axes kind of unique he's
half British half American actually and
so I maybe you know you're gonna full
British on us and Lawrence doesn't gonna
have that full Brit I don't know I'm
just grasping at straws here yeah we
don't wanna give a shout out to you know
we've over 10,000 people across all
platforms and whether you're watching a
chess TV YouTube twitch you name it we
appreciate you it's been so much fun for
us not so fun for Lawrence Trent right
now is he is down quite a lot in this
match but he still has chances and Danya
the question that I want to have
answered you were
joking about it when you were doing me
John impression when are we gonna get a
skin maven is he gonna treat us in the
bullet well in order to get a skin Navy
and Lauren still has to play eat for so
that pages on on that and I'm not sure
Lawrence's any plans applying e4 through
teams candy players make Scandinavians
happen okay John did play d5 I mean
nobody's like maybe she's a he should
play e5 against e4 by the way tons of
tactics now by Lawrence Bishop takes age
six and queen Chi six this is looking
very dicey for John maybe King h8 but
maybe John will play D 4500 Queen Bishop
h6 but there's 97 at the end so John is
just saying I'm gonna be cool in the
face of pressure queen g 6k h 8o at
bishop of 7 is positive queen 697 so
close
what about Queen g6 here night h7 rogue
g6 no 56 Bishop h6 Bishop e5
no but you H to check oh I was hoping
you would do something like that
haha those the kids why do they exist
you know you're usually one finding
awesome tactics occasionally I need my
time to shine in his way that was a nice
smooth nice flourish Queen g6 played
okay don't follow my advice little horns
you sure to learn that in the first
match 95 wow that may be even more
precise I don't know that hits the
bishop actually this is a great move it
is I think Lauren's got too excited he
should have kept the pressure going real
keep one maybe there yeah yeah so kind
of managed forward f5 or rook e1 as you
were saying looked better than this
because that 92 for Queen a for the f7
pot still is a weakness but Knight f6
here for black than 95 so actually I
don't want to speak too soon there's a
lot of pressure on that f7 bomb he's
Devin leaders impression there's a bone
in ooh yes but I still think that he's
let John off the hook Queen f6 by the
way Queen c7 still poking and prodding
although there may be 96 attacking the
bishop I'm just this looks like it's
firing out of control for Lauren's to be
honest especially given the dominating
initiative he had a little bit earlier
yeah and Jonathon extremely well that 95
move was really high-class and he found
his relatively quickly and now though
he's down 20 plus seconds and he took
that pawn I just gotta give a shout-out
to Jon's tactics in this match man he
has been so incredibly alert basically
after Game one but we'd be too you see
going overboard after a rookie to be one
what is his idea Queen f6 Queen f6 and
just trade Queens if he can I've never
seen John trade Queens before but I'll
take your word for it
I'm looking at Queenie for just hitting
the vision 27 giving my next food weave
rook to be one and the place for
everyone first of Queen f6 here I don't
know what White's response is going to
be if you take on f6 then 90 except say
how bad is that room d800 p7
doesn't why I have a lot of pressure
there with 95
the f7 part is the we square really the
week square now the issue is black could
even give that up somehow but I'm not
sure who's the one fighting for equality
it might very well be blood
actually this dozen is hard to protect
47 if there is in the check first and
Bishop d6 what do you pay 47 yeah right
so now with observers seven check I
guess but I would still bring up seven
King u6 that's see fun far advanced Oh
rook d7 rookie 795 be six my goodness
shine
oh but might be six there's rook to e8
and this should be three and Bishop six
g3 yes you don't want to put the rooks
oh this is happy Knight b6
here's Knight b6 rope d8 Bishop Easter
probably takes on f7 I'm not sure that
okay he's just stealing all the points
on nine age four oh shoot is that a
checkmate it might would be you can you
stop Bishop e7 Bishop e7 Bishop e7 he's
hanging by a thread night I find now the
bishops cut what is going on here this
is ridiculous
look up seventy-eights there's no me yet
there's no me but oh gosh it's so close
to was a yeah that didn't look good that
way I did not would get it oh that was
96 check one the bishop he wouldn't show
but c2 I was gonna see two there Robert
what would three oh you see three
because that night defended the bishop
now it's a game again and well it's
Lawrence's game right now Knight GA
check win gauge six ones it is and oh
what a free night you said you always
say that John loves putting a piece of
d5 square does he loves it a little too
much because no John saying right now
nothing well guys that was a tough game
for me and yeah I don't know what he's
saying you do it better than I do like
man he might depending on how frustrated
he is the addition of the words man if
he's a little for us to say ah man he's
you know raging just waging throwing
stuff ringing man and man
and a Manman not my way that didn't go
my way
Lawrence though ever 6g for Trump
tonight that oh my god yeah it was a
mouse slip for the ages he meant to go
f5o Benoni fashion see those Bishop h5
is miserable one i-74 who's this kind of
Bobby Fischer like right you did a CH
pawn and look at this there's actually
some counter play here there is f6 was I
mean seriously that is one of the worst
mess ups you could possibly imagine it
jumped remote Bishop e2 I I don't think
so he spent one point seven seconds so
that's a strange prima but g4 traps the
pony I age five so we get to the live
position here counts as Queen side and I
don't know I'm looking at some kind of
96 94 Bishop f5 trying to make an attack
happen yeah I mean this is very good at
a six-night before Bishop f5 looks very
good indeed this these positions with
the absence of a light square Bishop
Robert sometimes they arise in the Kings
Indian that's happened a couple times in
my games
I've always enjoyed playing against the
d5 I'm not sure about I feel like he
should have started by developing that
night but this also looks quite
formidable of course he's just trying to
kick the knight from c3 and go for an
attack but the problem is the d6 pawn is
so weak he put special buy five now
Knight takes d5 there's gonna clean b7
at the right moment check me maybe Quinn
qi5 for John yeah we g5 it kind of Queen
c7
ish good g3 I see issues because I don't
really know what's going on and it felt
like the thing to say I'm trying to get
my queen over to a five and deliver
check man you're trying to win on my
pawn so here's a mean guy
I know if Queen c7 Queen g3 I've rigged
up six in a row g6 yeah so I was worried
there about Queen g3 rigged up six and
then I go for 94 of g6
Bishop d6 even maybe just crashing
through because it's mean eventually
you're gonna run out of the material
yeah but I don't need my material all I
need use my Queen to go run over to the
king to your king and deliver checkmate
this is not what john wants right when
you're bored with f6 and of course even
ignoring trapping that piece on h5 it's
like you got a
temple in the opening and not 94 I'm
looking at Queen 85 try and just take on
a two but concretely Queen at five
bishop takes c6 I'm not seeing it
because Queen a two met with Bishop e5 I
realize it's very flimsy John the
hottest type of position but sometimes
you have to go for a position like this
in order to win the game right so 97
played here but now she's covering me
five square so it's an exchange
sacrifice
really I'm necessity but I like it
because now the Queen comes to a 5 and a
2 s hard defend because he played a 3
you welcome B for chiseling open to
Queen side if you Richard King on b1 but
now you can't because there's a bishop
there so but you know just good
discovery do you it depends I mean what
whoa whoa whoa whoa Robert Knight a5 95
rook air-five
Queen f5 yes it's my way Queen B 1 is
coming in I think Lawrence with a
grimace John just got to find one move
Queen B 1 that's literally the whole
operation down one yeah I mean you play
f6 on move whatever it was and you know
it's a mouse slip it's unfortunate
because Lord's had the momentum he'd won
two straight games all right and now
you're left in this position and John
still has a little bit of work here now
because c4 Knight c5 if I get those
moves in I have my d3 check I might be
three check so your king is not
perfectly safe and plays like d6 please
take me on c5 we go rook c8 yeah John
totally gonna do that
maybe d6 see them because night c4
though I like the way Lawrence's is
fighting in this out
Bishop c3 Queen c4 complete now 53
though we need to do anything wins
all roads lead to Rome here or to
Minneapolis
so if Queen before you a d6 check the 94
and there's some pressure here I guess a
a little bit maybe but since you're 7
yeah Queen a 3-week take on a3 take on
c3 you're gonna win oh wait that was a
big chance look at those pots that that
was not that clear take take three do
not tell me John is gonna repeat
was here that would be quite hilarious I
move he goes there but not 94 d7 though
I'm you should see three Queen and then
Queen a7 and all of a sudden the
fortunes turn right maybe to seven rooty
it actually staves off the median threat
of promotion and look at a time whoa
what does that move
Oh Bishop takes c3 BC 90 okey go now III
check when I spent haha oh my goodness I
missed that too much I was gonna be
suggesting g3 I mean what are we going
or necessary in archaea vs. Magnus
Carlsen hey eggs good a good reference
and there's just so little that can be
done from black King h8 prophylaxis
alpha zero it's just more like zero then
zero on the score shape is there
anything here King h8 it's probably the
move you kind of have fun at King f8 but
can't be just d7 anyway this is a sad
position 85 so Queen B three trades
Queens right nope okay d7 Queen b3 just
ends it
you can't down south the Queen trade
broke up John
there we go there we have it that's such
a debilitating move to face for me
personally that's one of those annoying
things when your opponent just trades
Queens of material and you know the game
is basically over
Florence fighting tooth and nail here
can be won though there's just too
little so what he wants some kind of
rook a one checkmate it's not gonna
happen a d8 equals da guei that price
should be seventy more precise probably
wait a second are you sure it's more
precise well it's still winning just
because of the abundance of material but
a3 cutting it close
it's John right because if a three-night
a3 rook a three I'm throwing brook a1
checkmate when you get a queen on d8 so
there should be a plate out takes 24
just like any night mootai 7 to c6 wins
the brook because my rook protects d7
yep and the pawns I'm not enough of a
force that is a very big one by John
quite possibly taking us the last game
of the 3-minute section a 5 point lead
going into bullet is all but
insurmountable
had Lawrence won that game it would have
been a three-point game you think about
it that's a humongous swing it is and
we'll have to ask Lawrence in the post
match interview if the Masters uses to
go this way and there's that copy
he started by you know slowly putting it
to the corner is enough now he's just
full-on into the center of his mouth
just dumping that inches that's how you
don't he's excited how he drinks his
coffee but what I was gonna say Tonya's
will have to ask Lawrence if the mass
continues to go this way and John pulls
it out if he feels like of course
there's already likely probabilistically
speaking that John is going to win the
match but you won two games in a row all
Momentum's on your side and then you
mouth some f6 that just takes the you
know just takes it all out of you
there's the it feels really just
deflating honestly yeah I feel like
Lawrence might start I don't know
quoting Charles Dickens in return this
is a response I really hope he doesn't
do that but you know Dickens and books
are really long
and so oh don't remind me of reading
those books anyway out to happier times
happier moments I didn't enjoy there's
another vigorous vigorous sip of the
coffee and Queen takes p6 by Lawrence
but those pawns Robert they've occurred
several times throughout the matches
where on the one hand they are doubled
on the other hand the gate file is open
that pawn mass is actually very very
solid it can be a strength as well as a
weakness yeah and the pawns in the Queen
side I think typically are a strength
inside position because you can play b5
and you have this solid chain from b7 c6
b5 and typically when you see them with
like b5 you look at the c6 bond have to
worry about it but not in a position
like this where there is another pawn on
b7 the rook on a a an active one on the
semi open filed a broken a1 a defensive
piece protecting this upon me too and
the bish when I tried that can become a
problem for black so f6 should be a
consideration maybe an e5 push and bring
the bishop to f7 mm-hmm absolutely very
solid that eight file Lords could come
to regret it I mean John
absolutely obviously taking its time
here let's see how long remains three
minutes 50 seconds he definitely wants
to believe the clock here a draw
absolutely satisfies him but if he ends
this on a win basically he can he can
just relax now Bishop f6 and castles
there's this idea of meeting he five
with Bishop 65 how does weight defend
upon
I was thinking Bishop before instead of
Bishop of safety this is also good
castles councils oh and the pawn on e5
this is nice look at you nice tie to the
funds is exactly this isn't a lot and
also because you can't even take because
of rook t2 works the bishops this isn't
this is completely lost losing to pawns
in a row the dominoes fall and Lauren's
out all over his face he's so pained yes
he is and he is he is saying a lot of
things and and John there we go again
tilting the angle of the coffee cup now
rising with each step I don't know if
there's anything in there I mean I've
taken as many sips of coffee as John has
I filled it to the brim I don't have any
coffee left I think that's just an empty
cup it's so awesome
he's got like you know a nervous habit
he's got a tick where he's just I gotta
bring that coffee up rookie 400 much
like mopping everything up that's what
I'm gonna do to the dust in my apartment
after this match is over just mop
everything about perky for Bishop e2 I
don't know if I would do that though
because the f7 part falls in the end of
that yeah exactly so it is one of those
things that just it looks better than it
actually is Heep is looking at that a4
pawn so I want to take that tray over H
to d8 should I play f5 you've so many
good moves here
I've worked exceed four is just that one
chance that Lauren J needs to try to
come back in this game yeah that was
impulsive you're absolutely right 94
John that's one of his strengths and we
played a ton of blitz games he catches
me a lot of battle making a pulse of
move thinking the game is over very very
tricky and he doesn't do that
he's always clinical and here we see an
ID for up three pawns
just and some tiny slivers of Ghana
played but virtually nothing because of
that incredibly solid pawn chain b7 c6
he can drop the knight back to p6 it's
not looking good for once
yeah Lawrence I mean Bishop to b5 is
maybe this is kind of like giving Brooke
a 7 he's at this point just praying for
something but it looks like a whole lot
of nothing
yeah I'm Knight b6 maybe this was kind
of nice e5 though and ever okay seven
you know it's perhaps not quite as
simple as you made it out to be
yeah but rook did the meeting we're k7o
31 like you said Robert just like
Lauren's and Trent's pre-match speeches
a whole lot of nothing hear that what a
John move rookie offering of rook
exchange now 92 p75 Bishop takes c6 is a
big threat yeah take this Bishop on b5
because when do you take it look at your
king look at the rook on c1 so Bishop g6
thrown in rook to be too quickly and now
there's 24 seconds night I came of your
night because then be some really is
falling oh my gosh there's that rook
team look at that rook e8 Bishop g6 and
and rook to b8 so fundamentally sound
every piece is on a healthy good square
it's just so infuriating to play John I
mean you know it's it's fun to watch him
though because as long as I'm not on the
receiving end of his really nice precise
moves it's just fun to see so just
technically sound player and Knight a6
check just going for tricks doesn't work
any kind of matings b7 doesn't work
those rook e1 check as an intermezzo so
this is just over rook t1 is just such a
buzzkill because that Bishop is gonna be
hanging let's not forget like it's three
hole punch up so there's just nothing
here for Lawrence and time is up this is
going to be the last game I was going to
say Lawrence should have resigned and
try it one more three game in because
now we're three six point lead and a
five point lead would still be tough but
a 6 point lead I mean I don't even have
enough games to play it so yeah 25
minutes on the clock
John is an incredibly strong bullet
player just just not good for Lawrence
Roque just streaming in no Bishop g6
drop everything back that rookie move is
so annoying
because you know you take if you take it
on a the night
nobody likes a 19-8 but it's just up
material yeah look at him to push his
pawns now and he's gonna take another
sip of his his mythical non-existent
coffee I guarantee you oh we were just
complimenting him and he just blundered
a full rook and rent
it's a Man Man Man Man Man that's five
shakes for five man's oh my god man this
is big this is big ladies and gentlemen
I just really lost mr. G to you when I
cannot believe that I've really just
freaked out there he just blundered a
full rook and he's holding on actually
Lauren's got some work to do but this is
of course he's going to win this oh that
hurts that does just I mean the only
thing you could have blundered and kudos
to Lawrence for staying in the game but
John that must hurt
and kudos to John by the way because he
could have just resigned wait a sec eggs
and c4 yeah this is getting scary
honestly I would have taken actually and
gone see boys position to be very hard
to win wait why do you raise King around
to a fun but he's just trying to stay in
the center look at this door this is not
over yet John Bishop e8 it should be a
proverb Bishop d3 b 3k t4o
like an oligo bishop eh 85 c4 also with
Emma take g6 ticket 5 but Bishop b4
ok picture of 7 more I got c4 c3 oh he
let the pawns go c3 King III oh my gosh
3d - no no no not this way now he can
give up to the rook for the bishop oh my
gos but is this winning King e6
how does white win no what is he doing
he's not gonna make Evan it says he C to
play C - no it doesn't do it doesn't
quite do the trick that Queen and I
usually get gone King d3 coming picture
figs b3 so yeah Laurens just got to see
one move and he goes off and now somehow
someway wayward Trent stays in this
match by hook or by crook he makes it
happen
he had a four point game still a
humongous lead for John but at least
decides to summon streak
and we needed we need to let both of
these flares catch a well-deserved
breath we're gonna go back an instant
replay that moment here King to d8 he
was worried about 95 check with the fork
and he walks into a different fork all
together - King D 896 check not
something you see happen John barthélemy
practically ever we cursed the guy I'm
so sorry John
but credit to Lawrence Trent he looked
like he wanted to resign he willed
himself to keep playing he ends up
winning the rook and winning the game we
will be right back in a few minutes with
the bullet portion of this I am non-gm
speeches ship to match brought to you by
chess calm
[Music]
well the I am not GM speed chess
champion is not the only event brought
to you by chess calm there are so many
happening now and in the near future
there is the premium arenas which I know
my good friend here date on their disc
ease and stop commentating and start
playing
because for premium members only get two
hours of three or blitz you get to play
the likes of Hikaru Nakamura your Daniel
Meredith's DS and maybe even your Robert
Hess's if I just dust off the pieces and
go play so Danya that's gonna be
exciting absolutely and please do dust
off the pieces because you're not too
shabby yourself but that's not the only
event that we have upcoming that's one
of several fascinating tournaments that
you are gonna be want to be a part of
and of course prizes are also very very
generous but there's also the online
Nations Cup from May 5th through 10th
another very very interesting
tournaments that's gonna be a fabulous
one you have teams from the USA India
China Russia European team and rest the
world team Alireza firoozeh at carro
Nakamura
Fabiano Karl wanna you have video
Gujarati playing along with Vishwanatha
on and Dingley Ren Wang how you name
these top players from the countries
they're gonna be there so that will be
brought to you Susan chess calm so that
will be a great event with all the top
players in the world and of course there
is another event for Europeans only
Danya sad day for us we can't play every
single event we want to play but it's
going to be a great one the European
online chess champ ship coming May 16th
so much chefs
ahead indeed put that in your calendar
May 16th but we have more fascinating
chess ahead in the form of a 25-minute
bullet section where Lawrence Trenton
passed him out an absolutely historic
comeback but that's been done before you
know how fired up he is Robert you
usually ask me these questions let me
turn the tables to you how do you rank
Lawrence's chances do you think it's
realistic to believe that he's actually
going to make this a close match well
Lawrence says no to bring mayhem to the
board so if he can create that chaos and
I'm a little concerned about John
because I know we joked that he's always
stoic and he has the same exact facial
expression
losing a game like that when you could
have practice ice to match and then you
lose it one bullet game and they maybe a
second one that really hurts your
confidence right now Lawrence playing
this modern defense very slow approach
Bishop c4 by JB and look at this
triangle B to the D for two f2 very
solid play by John thus far indeed
unbreakable and John with a proven
bullet pedigree Bishop a6 here by the
way pretty decent he's fast when he
needs to be John likes to take his time
but he ain't no 25 96 he's definitely
underrated I've seen in the over 2700
Lauren's 25 25 sounds about right
again I'm not familiar with whether he's
a very good bullet player mediocre
bullet player I guess everything will be
revealed this is a crucial for a scam
Robert because if John wins this is that
I don't want to say that ends it but
basically this is a must-win for
Lawrence yes and Lawrence is very good
at dodging bullets when people are
attacking the chessboard and bullet is
Mike one of my favorite characters in
the show the killing but that's not a
here nor there and right now you see
that Lawrence is trying to get his Queen
on the court out of the corner
plays 860 good night away and look at
this setup black a super solid upon the
e7 and d6 the bishop on h2 is blunted
and that's really key because sometimes
these London type of structures the
bishop gets loose and all of a sudden
blacks position becomes problematic but
now that queen is on c7 Queen PA
offering the Queen trade you take it
down you and you leave it don't leave it
that Queen on c6 this is if there is a
single position that most characterizes
most epitomizes John it's this when he's
got that pressure Knight c4 no
weaknesses super solid Knight drives
into a 5 this is not what Lawrence was
looking for from the first game now with
that being said a draw is better than a
loss if you can hold this together round
quickly you much much better off but now
Bishop c7 is in the mix this is looking
very very suspicious for black when I
say it with that London Bishop when it
comes to life it comes in full force in
Bishop d7 is that Queen away and Donnie
I want to point out that the key word
when you were saying is quickly because
John can milk so much time off the match
clock right here and even if he doesn't
convert this position it does look
good for him and you're maybe winning
just because on a six is the biggest
target that just wasting another minute
and a half of the match clock is really
bad for Lawrence yeah he's going hunting
for that pawn 91 becomes an idea 95 but
now how does he avoid oh look at that
passer but c6 is just coming in and
Bishop e5 against that f6 this could
just be promotion five is beautiful 94
and I don't you move Knight b6 but then
just take on a6 and look at that knight
on f6 g5 q g6 good job I look 95 and
then Bishop f6 97 check that's really
nice King g6 peeks of 697 so you can't
do it before threat 1997 yep look at
that find we talked about how JB has
been alert all day flying a tactic and
now he just up a piece and I think with
that it's the match is not quite ice but
it's getting there it's really getting
there and he took a chunk is it Lawrence
has got to resign this he took a chunk
of time off the clock basically four
minutes
inez won the game here we see
resignation but five-point lead I mean
this is gonna be a bow if he makes this
happen and here we see the birds defense
it's the it's not a defense it's the
opening come on birds opening the trend
variation the reverse touch and yeah
this is just he's clearly just upset and
going for it but it's not a bad weapon
in billet because your plans go G for
Queen h4 go for an attack on the Kings
side and in bullet chess King safety is
so so so essential that if you can scare
your opponent it's often more valuable
than actually you know playing the slow
approach and the strategic improve EF
timely it's the most important factor
you know Knight g5 and ace wasting Oh h6
where does the knight go John driving
the rook into e2 he's banking on that 97
Guardian and I don't have six not on f6
defends the pawn on e4
d4 oh man that's painful cos g2 because
Rick is this just lost for white it
looks losing because you already five no
Rosie - but that's the only kind of
thing to dislodge the night from f6 to
get Queen e7 checkmate also be 45 and
Quidditch - oh man
everything if the bishop moves is create
shoot come you're right FG and if
there's a cheat
yo doesn't have to hurry you can do this
- this is crushing I mean blacks attacks
so much weightier than whites whites in
South not not doesn't even exist cuz ya
Afghan King gate shading King is perfect
become queen is joining me yep and John
sees it instantly yeah John's a beast
this is a runaway train I mean I was a
six-point lead 20 minutes to go
this is all but over and John's full
rating back over 2600 and I mean he's
just really playing well and Lawrence's
jobs below 2500 but it's just a
testament to John Schrank we have eight
sort of a French with a 9 @ c6 what's
that night doing there that's like a
weird McCutchen but 94 actually I like
the way Lawrence has made this I don't
like bishops III though this is a great
position for white because that knight
on c6 blocking the pawn on c7 which
normally belongs on c5 in the French
otherwise white pawn chain in the center
force to be reckoned with rook h3 John C
for displaying pretty good knowledge of
these ideas even though he's not any
four player nobody knows that he used
the scores like d5 because that seems
candy guy but now this d4 pawn that's a
weakness Bishop of three dreading yeah
warp on ABC 4 was rushed and there
should be found look at that by Lawrence
taking over these squares the c-4 square
is not blacks Queen d7 hitting the pump
there was no threat I would have just
Castle it cuz Queen a for that was
Bishop e5 check that's true but this is
fine for a white as well I mean this is
gonna take an eon for black to win if he
ends up winning I would take on a 4 and
a 6 English go D 5 D 5 6 C 5 e 6 95 it
was nasty and he just plays like this
he's playing the John style that we all
know and love
very solid doesn't want to commit to
anything doesn't want to get too
tactical in case it backfires look at
him H over 90 you can just see for he
wants against Queen e4 and not happening
since Bishop c2 just attacking this
Knight yeah just fine how he wants Queen
f5 now that's John's version of a pawn
sacrifice carving at the diagonal I love
it it's a pawn sacrifice just a great
move
95 is a very nice response it is very
resourceful maybe 94 I mean at this
point Wow and look at that tactical
awareness Bishop h7 check yep there's
always this yawn on top the whole match
but I'm not sure this this could
backfire the pawn on d6 could be a big
weakness in the end game and good vision
by Lawrence play Queen f6 because all of
the Queen moves did not look very good
this much were promising to pawn on d6
rook d7 worked in d8 in that pond maybe
lost he takes on f3 first now there's my
b7 back to c5 because the d6 pawn cannot
be protected if it goes to d7 is connect
back to c5 so he chooses this way he's
going to take the slower approach piling
up pressure on the d6 pawn but here
comes repeater one who's gonna be hard
to crack once again that pawn on d6
black needs to attend to that pot
constantly which means basically one of
his rooks is gonna be tied down I don't
know I mean this is not gonna be easy to
win he's trying to retool his rooks but
again that pawn on d6 permanent weakness
basically and just a little bit of
shuffling here breath like a king can go
g7 f88 d7 but that's a long journey that
king is take a long walk there and now
II five at some moment from black just
trying to break open I like what John's
doing though transferring the bishop to
wrap 3 to c6 that's not gonna be fun
because now once I take any 276 balls
maybe e5 but that does not look like a
step in the right direction I think you
have to do something like that though
yeah otherwise
oh definitely he hung the rook a just
hung the rook oh my gosh Laurence look
to the side has psy resignation in a
quite a literal resignation yeah
literally a sigh as I followed by
resignation
oh man that's there's you know when back
just get out of hand
it becomes very painfully even though we
feel bad for the losing player no matter
who it is just something is a little bit
different when it's a close match that
could have gone either way you're like
wow that was crazy
we're excited it's an electric
atmosphere but when it's so one-sided as
the score now is it just starts feeling
I just feel sad whoa what's going on
this what is happening I what
aagh there is a line of this love
similar to this where I've seen this
happen but a kind of a bus killed by
John I would have seen this is the one
time client for the analysis for it
because we need to see that position I
think that the fans deserved it and we
should give John some grief about it
because there's always winning even
though he's winning because it means to
go back in time we're gonna go on the
analysis board here that in this line
you can take on a one you take on h8 and
how often do you get treated position
with four queens just like this you
don't get this very often so it's a
little bit upsetting that John didn't go
for it's probably bad for black which is
why he's going for it but I just want to
stare at the position alone me too by
the way John is about to win Queen takes
a job with a savage tactic wins the game
but still I mean he should have done
this for the fans bad John had John I
think we shouldn't invite him back on
solely on that basis we take c1 what a
way to finish that game oh look at look
at what's happening or he's just mowing
down one row gosh just the other day the
way for that bond so you know what he
did there he didn't want for Queens you
want to sacrifice his Queen so he got a
new one
I still feel like we lost an opportunity
there absolutely did he just take a sip
of coffee because I missed him did John
actually take another sip of coffee
because there's definitely there is
nothing but M zenus in that cup hey
maybe he is like five of the same exact
cups have you thought about that you
didn't think about that did you
I love the same exact cups see you got
think outside the box really well John
II think John did that much thinking in
preparation
he didn't even prepare for the warrant
he thought about what I would think
about his coffee drinking habits and the
fact that I would notice them so let's
prepare same type of mug
no more very plausible lager or wasn't
prepared
he's just have to be sponsored by
whatever is that a Starbucks mug I don't
know what it is but I don't drink coffee
but he's sponsored by it so he just has
a collection of them and so he just goes
from one to the other he pours all scoff
in advance I would anticipate well
honestly the thing
revealing though is when you're drinking
coffee you take a sip right you tilt it
tilted slowly you don't bring it up to
your mouth and then tilt it all in one
motion as he's doing he's doing this
that means the coffee is gonna spill out
if there's actually any coffee left so I
have caught him red-handed I think we
should not invite him from a man I think
you're just mean muggin what's going on
is there peace last year just blonder to
peace yeah you see what I did to him
yeah you called outdoor John is this the
clearest position I mean if you could
somehow get to d7 pawn and it collapse
the whole pawn structure maybe the
chance but you don't if you ever need a
coffee private investigator any of your
friends you think they're fooling you
into thinking that they're drinking
coffee when they're not you know how to
turn to can we just talk about this
polishing from disseminations let's talk
about the Fon Chang oh it's gone okay
somehow staying in the game by the way
it just hurts to see this because for
Lauren's any fine gets a winning
position oh gosh what some checks did
rookie one check with D one check
overseas III that MKC three nothing
going his way he walked right into that
and rook c2 literally nothing going his
way Brooke TT would see two in Group G
two there and then you just try being a
king in I would go rookie - but then he
g7 the king is in time yes the king is
gonna be in time and the rook wants to
stay attached to this pawn age - an e6 I
would just draw this cuz I would be a
little bit concerned about losing H -
whoa what soon okay whatever yeah this
hey King c4 there a c4 is just winning
yeah there's the rook g2 that I was
calling for you can never take on Jimmy
you know but you can go rookie chu and
King III but then I'll go ripped you won
so I think made you really commit to
something
Oh King III three filthy oh my god - its
man oh man
Man Man Man Man Man Man Lawrence is
definitely not saying Man Man Man he's
saying something something something
yeah expletive expletive expose words
are not men
oh and I am Rosen shadows air grows in
the chat he was a great presence in this
I'm not Jim speed Chess Championship he
lost will Lina caption sky up John of
the smiled all the way yeah we do have a
smile
hey you know it was forced out of him he
finally he smiles but I just want to
give you a phone I think he's watching
us smiling and so he's smiling he's
doing it for the fans
is Lauren what in the world by the right
Lopez Queen variation yeah I don't get
it but b7 f5 both hanging oh I guess if
you take on b7 you're gonna have a world
of problems there P if I my next before
Judge Marilyn and night before resigns
Queen c4 ooh one last trick still this
has lost her wait are you telling me
that you can't move the same piece over
and over and over and over and over and
over again and get away with it that's
exactly what I'm sorry I don't know
where you learned that principle from
but somehow Laurence's through through
some incredible gymnastics for this
Queen he's staying in the game I would
sagar he's on the body it's probably
better now if I wanted to fool around I
do Queen t4 here with black and that hey
hey you understand John Bartholomew I do
I've told you I wasn't lying when I said
we've been friends many many years I
think I know how that twisted brain
waves were et 392 and is nice to three
wow what a thorns look at that lolling
out all the stops here and King D 1 and
if he loses this one don't Susan don't
you even suggest that's the consolation
goal this is his chance at a serious
consolation ball
see three can see to slowly expand he's
doing everything right so far except the
opening but John is trying hard not to
smile right now I can just tell he's
just he's holding his like chattering I
described that pose I mean he he really
looks like he's about to come up with
some new wave of philosophy yeah he's
thinking through Friedrich Nietzsche
penetrating the bishop's yep and how
about nine and a half plus minutes left
of this match
that's tough don't blend another four
check you didn't and white is still up
upon but I like what John's doing you're
starting to massage those pawns that
knight on d5 guess where it is d5 what a
big surprise
85 trying to get for under 87 Knight f6
yep a timely 94 will be nice for blood
to undermine the protection that beast
three square and if anyone nice to five
check and the Brooklyn ISA 95 95 95 is
better it's but silly we're checking her
mezzo look at the king it's going into G
for warrants lurid spotted it
Gabriel cage seven or two seven I would
just slice off all those pawns of all
you can done unhinged there DC though
mmm-hmm
that king what a savage oh my god so
these pawns going no white flying before
a 4-3 if just one night of six just do
it do it do it
okay now at 387 this is not over
actually hoji eight it's over yeah it is
Oh Queen grenades ooh creature was
really nice grano Amano 92 what a
elegant British checkmate and the Lord
takes one he now is down 14 to 6 in the
match score and I mean just you know I
think the way he looked says it all he
is really upset without this match is
gone he looks sad this is making me sad
yeah and it's just the problem is when
you're faced with such an insurmountable
advantage just motivating yourself to to
keep trying to find the best move in
every position is very difficult
at the same time you know scoring a
couple of consolation goals is also a
good feeling we remind the viewers that
there is some prize money tied into the
scores so there is definitely some
intrinsic motivation but this is another
buzz saw for John and that knight on c6
is so loose yeah that's not gonna be a
good look if your former root canal on
that c5 Queen 67 is coming in and then
the rook on ds9 defended because the
rook any seven blocks the Queen's
protection of it and you know you
brought up the prizes you know the
players largely are playing for the joy
of chess these are lifelong competitors
and I think you know I should bring this
up every time we're here covering this
action we love these players they're
very very strong to spend that you know
these are most of players the exception
of Teddy and I can't think of anybody
else our chess professionals and just to
become international mass you spend so
much time dedicate so much effort to the
game of chess and these are extremely
strong players in their own right and so
I just wanted to remind everybody of
that and also say that they're playing
for pride they play for some money and
any donation that is given goes to the
players pocket so if you're fan of John
Bartholomew your fan of Laurence Trent
you know donate away and especially at
this point I think Lawrence he could use
a little pick-me-up because he's down
fourteen six in this match and we
appreciate his fighting spirit and to
your point Robert that was very well
said very little that I have to add but
you know some people I told about this
match to they wave their hands yeah I am
it's literally in the title I am NOT a
GM how could this be interesting well I
challenge you to find a single match
that has been has hard-fought as
fascinating as virtually every one of
these matches these players are coming
and putting their hearts on to the game
onto every single game they're pouring
pouring their blood sweat and tears out
into the match so we have been treated
to some incredible chess and there's
some incredible chess of course still to
come in the decisive batches I do think
we've been spoiled a bit in particular
Ted Coleman with his two match victories
down to the very last game alina cash
and skya her victory over chess
explained in the opening round
and it just you know these matches
sometimes they become lop side that's
not unique to dis event in the speeches
championship we've seen many of the top
players lose by incredibly large margins
a remind of Levon Aronian beating fug on
a car wanna buy scores like twenty to
six alright you don't expect that to
happen you're just sometimes it does
happen and these players are giving it
their all they're preparing for the
matches and they're you know they want
to win and unfortunately this time
around for Lawrence he won his first
round of this match and everything after
this that first game went downhill for
him and kudos to John Bartholomew who as
cool as a cucumber he's now up a pawn in
this possession thing he's just gonna
play this one out for a bit I mean
either way it matches his but you're up
a pawn I would play this especially
because Knights when you venture Paul
with Knights on the board you have more
winning chances than with bishops in
this type of position indeed it's a
completely different kettle of fish and
you can see that in effect after King g6
there's Knight f4 check dislodging the
king then you take on f7 Lawrence that's
just pure desperation I mean that's
probably not gonna get it done but yeah
I mean I think it was a combination here
tactical Sharpe and Shawn was just much
more tactically alert when things came
down to these highly tactical scramble
three drum and as I say he stacks to the
alert a blunder stuff but it doesn't
matter anymore he just out calculated
Lawrence what in the world you've
definitely spoke too soon I have
goodness okay but it's still a draw yes
just don't blender the rook too
but your your deep you give a shoutout
to John before ivory never mind forget
it
he can only redeem himself by taking
another sip of that coffee yeah and I
see somebody asking the question I
wouldn't ask what's a kettle of fish no
it's an expression a different kettle of
fish isn't that the expression I mean I
know really heard him you can also say a
different cup of tea
I mean kettle of fish is something that
is that an expression or am I just
inventing that somebody's got to confirm
it well I just googled it and kettle of
fish is a neighborhood bar in Greenwich
Village
so another fish expression the
expression of kettle of fish is usually
part of the phrase a different kettle of
fish as a separate meaning which is an
alternative a different thing altogether
Robert did you hear what I just said
that's right I mean I looked it up and I
saw the same thing that you just read I
like the thing that I read a little more
though well I like the thing I read a
little bit more so okay well I'm glad we
agree to disagree I'm so glad we're not
commenting together tonight
hey Cho Robert I just I think it cooled
down I mean I'm just I don't know what
to say to you right now I don't know
it's a to you and now your feet traps
the Queen miss an opportunity there man
man man but it's now rookie figure I
don't you think you were doing on
purpose there with the man man man I
think you just I was opting in oh gosh
yeah 95 by the way when's the camera
kept 395 as a blow and there it is
straight lines inspired in the last
games of the match got to give him gotta
give him credit I mean he is either
playing it out easy it don't be nice to
it has to be all those live Queen t6
here yeah boo Queen t6 protects the d5
on tax f6 + f6 Falls
I mean wait G to start taking the pawns
here ok you should take a teacher first
somebody just savage in the chat saying
my equips are lasted salad 1565 England
there's there's a bunch of
I want to say in response to that but I
won't say any of them I'm just gonna
feel I'm feeling nice don't just let the
words fall out man I was just gonna say
that's no don't say it's not already say
just the way you're hesitating makes me
know that you shouldn't say what you
want to say it was a bad bad but I would
say it felt like it was going to be bad
and I wanted to protect you so it
involved someone's face that's all I'm
gonna say yeah no just want it done
yeah tone it down my fair enough you
know all the jokes we make about you
getting fired and I do enjoy
commentating with you so I'm just trying
to make sure that you don't get baited
by the twitch chat and say something
that you regret hahahahahaha thank you I
know you're always looking out for me
Robert no I like I said earlier I tried
to be the responsible one when I can
fair enough fair enough we'll see the
last time the match how much time to be
like I think there will be one more game
once John resigns this which he will
make 3 after this brutal attacking with
a three wait he can actually run out the
match if he plays always moves quickly
yeah he can't I think that's what he's
trying to do
yeah just like you know I don't want to
play one more I don't have yeah guys
just want to go back and take a little
breather a YouTube video will be posted
to my channel later exactly you're
getting the hang of it if you don't see
a YouTube channel video tonight well I
just we've got a little busy I had my
speech just champion match and well I
just lost that game but it's ok guys I
have a you're good nice I like it I
didn't leak to you you know so you said
hey guys it's John it gets done yeah
that voice is starting to get and that's
what I've been struggling with with
warrants I've never been good at a
British British accent actually that's
been one of my biggest weaknesses it's
okay
Bishop d5 yeah that's a very interesting
move John going out on a major limb
planky for and I think he's surprised to
find no limbs fell out from him when he
played 180 for it to borrow the Russian
expression last popular in 1566 well we
haven't had a Scandinavian I'm just you
talked about before I'm thinking about
things like there has not been a scandi
like if I were Lawrence and you don't
have time to think as a bullet game but
if John if I eat four against me I'm
playing the scandi right absolutely
what's wrong John is uh let's just say
the effort level that John is putting in
this game is it's too high
sixteen percent how did you get the 16
I'm curious because the tilting it's the
tilt and I mean here it's the head you
see that mullet do you see the Queen
tell me that's where the sixteen game
from Robert Queen b6 is played I don't
even know and Morris of the spot at Java
the smadi / they both realize it that's
hilarious
and now black is up a pawn six yeah we
said the same time
high five down yeah kingi 798 I see six
hey I give you a high five high five
high five no it's too late now I feel
like that was just one sided rookie Eric
a7 oh my gosh well we're gonna take a
break because the players will join us
any moment so we will be right back with
these two to hear their thoughts about
what was a very fun matched be right
back
[Music]
and as we return to the match here it
just finished Lawrence Trent our
apologies on that result of course not
what you wanted but my first question
has to be do you have anything you want
to say to Greg Hardy anything I really
want to say I mean if I can avoid any
communication with its opponents but all
I'm gonna say is Greg you know you're
playing a very strong player this
afternoon and she's better than you
let's face it she's more talented and
I'm really hoping that she gives you a
good beating but I want to say
congratulations to John he deserved the
victory no question I felt as though I
had some very good positions on in the
match from the five-minute portion that
I didn't convert a number of games come
to mind when I have my rooks on the C
file and there were other ones and I
just didn't get my flow going there was
some Mouse Clips there was some blunders
and I wasn't as fresh today certainly as
I was against Kostya and John was just
very tricky when it came down to the
wire when it came to the times family
was better and then one minute when
there was a four-point deficit and I
still had a chance you know you've got
to get off to a flying start and when
you lose a few it's just all over I
found myself getting kind of in the
groove at the end of the one-minute but
it was too little too late and John on
your end it seemed like a very
well-played match after you lost that
first game you bounced back with five
straight wins and in that final game of
the three-minute portion when you just
blundered your rook in a winning
position you start to have some fear
trickle in but now it's only a four game
match and you're probably upset about
that blunder and anything can happen in
Bullitt a little bit not so much to fear
but it just puts a bad taste in your
mouth right heading into a different
time control but you know in a long
match like this there's gonna be breaks
either way yeah as Lawrence said there
were a couple games that came down to
the wire that I got that probably I
shouldn't have one of them was the sloth
game sloth game where he had this
pressure on the C file at an awkward
Bishop on c5 pinned by both of his rooks
and in a time scrambled Queen a night
like I somehow got
around as king and he lost but no I felt
like the bullet would go okay but these
matches are all about momentum - so you
know you do want to immediately try to
you know I lost three out of last four
games in the 3-1 wanted me to be try to
string together a couple wins in the
bullet well John congratulations I have
two questions for you one serious
question one super serious question
let's start with a serious question we
were impressed throughout with your
tactical awareness you found several
very impressive tactical blows the one
I'm thinking about is rookie seven
followed by 96 yeah do any special kind
of preparation psychological or puzzles
anything that you did consciously or did
you just kind of feel sharp coming into
the match the only thing I did is I
looked at Lawrence's match with Coast
yell a little bit just kind of looked at
the openings that he was playing as in
just literally try to get an assessment
of what he plays but I didn't do any
special preparation I did go back and
look at our deathmatch from a couple
years ago because that's when Lawrence
and I played a match for the first time
so I was just trying to get a feel for
what it was like back then but no
nothing special just trying to manage my
time which I think I did alright but
there were some games were it got out of
hand like Lawrence was definitely
pressing down the clock sometimes I
think I need to get to the super serious
question because I've just gotten 8,000
people very riled up about this them
throughout the match John
now we both started the match with mugs
of cod I assume you had coffee in your
mug of approximately the same size I
finished mine about halfway through the
five in a portion and I'm pretty sure we
took approximately the same number of
sips out of that Cup so we were starting
to wonder because the more games he won
the more vigorous your skills were from
the cup was there actually anything in
the cup or was it a instinct at what
point was that empty or did you feel my
twitch viewers shout out to the twitch
audience by the way you guys are awesome
they will know that I often just bring a
entire pot of coffee upstairs with me
from my kitchen so that's what I had
next to me and I was occasionally
refilling it but yes I slept over and
the mystery has been solved
I thought you had a sponsorship deal
where you had like five of the same
exact mugs you just poured coughing to
every single one Oh
switching off I got this one I have some
tea that I didn't touch its cold now but
uh no an infant and in total honesty I
slept terrible last night I've been like
very busy in a little bit stressed just
uh
personal life work wise a little bit
lately so nothing major but I think it
definitely affected my like
psychological preparation let's say
going into this match sign I know I
needed like a main line of caffeine to
keep me keep me steady veins just
injected well Lawrence you know like we
were saying of course it's matching the
way you wanted what do you think that
you should have done differently as you
you haven't really time to process and
look back but what could you have done
differently against John to have turned
the match in your favor I mean
ultimately when you play is somebody as
good as John you got to take your
chances there is nothing different per
se I would do i got the positions I
wanted I got the dynamic play I wanted
you could see all these Slav positions
you know he blade of the free
sub-optimal line with Bishop g4 I don't
know in depth that I can there are
various ways for me to get very pleasant
positions so it's not like I'd change my
openings I just didn't convert when I
needed to I mean there were at least two
or three games I can think right now in
the earlier portions if I'm within sort
of two points then it's a real match but
I felt like it was drifting and maybe I
could have been a bit sharper maybe I
could have yeah I also came in slightly
less fresh than I did the other day but
no you know you got up put your hand up
and say John was the better was the
better player took his chances and I
wish him I wish him all the best
especially if he plays Greg Hardy if
great manages to swindle his way through
against charissa yet because that's
really all he knows he does that and he
plays John next then you can bet your
bottom dollar I'm gonna be rooting for
John and he does you know plastic player
well thank you both so much for what was
a very fun match
again morons you know next time
hopefully better for you and John we'll
see you in the next round
congratulations and you know keep up
this momentum here yeah yeah thanks
Lawrence thank us thanks guys appreciate
it
thank you guys well you've heard it from
the players themselves
Lawrence Trent saying you know what
today was just John Bartholomew was a
better player than I was and so John
moves on to the semi-finals he awaits
the winner of Chrissie yet versus Gregg
jihadi it seems like they're friendly
barbs being thrown between and yeah you
know I think the end of the day is
friendly ribbing drove Reagan Lawrence
have this history of playing matches
against each other Craig has won those
but on a serious note that is a very
interesting matchup that will see at 6
p.m. Pacific time tonight will be
Carissa yet versus Greg jihadi I don't
even know who I favor at the moment
between those two I have way more
experience playing with Greg he's a
really fantastic player and we saw him
beat on a sitarski in the opening round
in a very tough matchup but Chrissy is a
very different style then on the place
Johanna is more technical more sound
Chris yep wisely more energetic chest
switch on when it could play into Greg's
favor because he enjoys that come just
the other hand when you you know fight
fire with fire
you're both didn't get burned indeed
charissa Shawn her tenacity she's shown
a tactical sharpness against Dina Pulido
I will unfortunately not be able to join
that evening match but I'll certainly
watch the playback and I look forward to
the games and this was yet another
interesting match obviously got out of
hands and John simply the better player
but Robert it's been a pleasure
commentating every single one of these
with you as much as you know the
roasting goes on at the end of the day
couldn't find a better commentating
partner so as we learn from John there's
always more coffee in the pot so let the
roast continue but Thank You Don your
your nice words you know I love
commentating alongside you I thank you
to all of the viewers here whether
you're watching my chess TV YouTube
twitch Facebook we really do appreciate
you it makes our job so much more fun
and the friendly chat and just
everyone's good just in the game of
chess just makes the world a better
place so thank you so much everybody
thank you guys
the IM non-gm speech has shipped you
brought to you by chest calm
there will be more later tonight
[Music]
you